good morning
welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee i am councillor mary
mclaren and i am chairing the meeting
today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain a social
distance from all of the persons in the
chamber and in the social areas
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless you are sitting down or if you
are unable to do so and that you use the
hand sanitizer and wipes provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting and during the
breaks
please ensure that micro microphones are
turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off additionally we
will be using e-voting for this meeting
on the modern.gov
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consent it to being
filled
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i would like to welcome the following
people to our meeting
we have got
kathy nixon strategic director
vicki mosley corporate manager
communities
and emily ewell monitoring officer
councillors in attendance
councillor derrick davis chairman of the
wscsp councillor sarah mansell vice
chairman of the wc scsp
and lead
wscsp member for mid-suffolk
we welcome superintendent janine ratten
western area commander wesser for
constabulary so welcome to all our
visitors thank you
we'll now proceed to the agenda
apologies for absence and substitutions
thank you chair we have received
apologies from councillor catherine
brandon councillor jane gould and
councillor dave miller
thank you
to receive declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interests by members
other only to declare
no
we're now going to item 7
on our agenda paper
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
non-received chair
any questions by the public now received
jeff and an item nine
questions by counsellors none received
jeff thank you
so we will now go directly to item 10
which is the main substance of our
meeting this morning
so that is
jos
stroke 25 review of western suffolk
community safety partnership
however
what i've realized as chair of this
meeting is that often the public are not
necessarily aware of some of our
internal policies so i'm just going to
clarify that for the public and those
watching on live stream the reason that
this item has come to
overview the joint overview and scrutiny
committee i think that would be helpful
for people
so it is because of section 19 of the
police and justice act which requires a
loc every local authority
to designate a committee to review and
scrutinize the activities of the crime
and disorder partnerships and the
activities of its partners
the committee may examine the activities
of partners
but only in safar as they relate to the
partnership thank you so i would like to
invite
councillor derrick davis who is the
chair
of
the partnership to introduce the report
jos
stroke 21 stroke25 thank you councillor
davis thank you chair
um i was appointed as the the chair of
the western suffolk community safety
partnership back in december
and i'd like to take this opportunity
first of all to
thank my predecessor joanna spicer for
all her hard work and commitment to the
partnership
through her tenure she really was
a force to be reckoned with so
i'm looking forward to
continuing the work that she's done
sarah was uh was also appointed at that
time as the vice chair
um
like joanna i'm committed to ensuring
that
the network of partnerships that make up
the wscsp
continue to deliver great work against
each of the priority areas in its action
plan
and focuses on the community safety
matters that affect all of our area
as stated in the report the western
suffolk csp is currently taking stock of
the work completed last year its
successes priorities and the impact that
it has made for our communities through
the annual strategic assessment as well
as having regard to the priorities set
out in the new police and crime
commissioners plan
we will also have a suite of new and
updated strategies to support the
delivery of action plan and i will be
encouraging a great emphasis on all of
us working together
to share data and knowledge to target
intervention where they are most needed
at the safer stronger communities
communities board at the beginning of
the year i was pleased to support the
new violence against women and girls
strategy
i am also very encouraged by the work
currently ongoing in relation to the
development of the modern slavery
strategy
locally in suffolk there have been 150
reports of modern slavery to suffolk
constabulary
for the year ending september to 2021
the csp has been responding to modern
savour at slavery for many years and
captures activity in its action plan
particularly in relation to raising
awareness
there has also been significant pros
progress with regards to asb and
improvements to the way we manage asb
including the
including at the councils
new councilwide procedures
increased capacity to respond to asb
review of all live asb cases
escalation process for the complex asb
cases
increased use of the victim impact
assessment with additional support for
victims and witnesses
improved web pages
improved community trigger process
training of officers and counsellors and
the implementation of case management
management system for the better sharing
of data
all of these were mentioned as you may
recall
in the stella marist review as and
report by anthony douglas
um i'm now a lot to take this
opportunity to introduce formerly uh
sarah mansell
the the vice chair
uh thank you derek i too would like to
take this opportunity to thank
councillor joanna spicer for all her
hard work and commitment that she has
shown to the partnership
the csp has an extensive action plan
which we review quarterly and what i'm
especially pleased to see is the
continued work towards and recent
revision to the county-wide violence
against women and girls strategy and
cuts across a number of the partnerships
other main priority areas such as
criminal exploitation and modern slavery
much work has taken place in this area
including the introduction of the 24 7
helpline satellite accommodation
continued da champion champions training
freedom program provision and the white
ribbon campaigns
in suffolk 19 of all recorded crime for
the year ending march 21 was related to
domestic abuse and this is fractionally
higher than the england and wales
average so there is still much for us to
do
the new strategy will guide and support
the continued work of the partnership on
this priority area focusing on
prevention supporting victims and
working together to change behaviours
i'm looking forward to receiving the
outcomes of the strategic assessment and
developing the partnerships action plan
for the year ahead
thank you
i think that's
that's you council davis
yeah so um i'd now like to take the
opportunity to introduce vicky who is
the assistant director and i'd also like
to add my thanks to her for her support
um
and the diligent homework that she does
in preparing reports and i'd also while
i've got the floor i'd like to thank
claire harvey and melanie yoland two
outstanding officers who i know were a
great help to join the spicer and have
just carried on the good work
through now so i'd like to introduce
vicki mosley
okay thank you very much uh
the
report you've got in front of you just
pretty much describes the the role of
opening scrutiny committee in reviewing
and examining the work of the csp over
the last year
um and for those of you that are not
aware the csp is made up of several
strategy representatives across the
the western area which includes baber
mid suffolk and western um suffolk
councils i include civic police the
county council suffolk fire and rescue
services both ccgs national probation
services and elected members so it's
quite and we also have um co-op teas on
there as well so we will also have other
health specialists but also educational
specialists as well who inform um
inform the work of the the csp vicky can
i just sorry can you move your
had a bit out of the way thank you and
so is that better
so we can hear better okay very much um
thank you
so in terms of the work of the
partnership as it's also already been
mentioned the partnership meets uh four
times a year and the purpose of those
meetings are to
review the action plan but also a number
of other sort of um
standard items so it also has
responsibility for reviewing um
progress against certain sort of police
crimes that were reported but also
but also domestic homicide reviews so we
also have updates on
dhrs if we have any in in the western
area
as as my report states we have three
currently ongoing at present
um
we are also
in the middle of completing our
strategic assessment so all csps in
suffolk are completing a strategic
assessment at the moment and suffer
county council will is
completing that piece of work for us so
that will again be reviewing the action
plan and the progress made on the action
plan but again it will be looking at
kind of crime and disorders of
information across the the counties and
also the csp area and will then um
inform us in terms of what our what our
priorities what the needs and what
that's those that information is telling
us and so we will use that information
then as a csp to generate and formulate
our new action plan for the next coming
for the forthcoming year
the current priorities as the report
sets out at the moment are criminal
exploitation violence against women and
girls hate crime prevent and modern
slavery so there are predominantly our
five key priorities and that's they're
the priorities that the action plan is
primarily based on and we break down
activity by awareness raising
communications projects and community
resilience we also
ensure that we again as i've mentioned
make sure that we also keep um asb and
domestic homicide reviews as priority
areas as well and we regularly review
those
so despite continuing to meet virtually
over the last year and some of our
activities have been limited by covert
restrictions the csp has continued to
make progress in all its priority areas
which i like land in the report and the
action plan that was appended to the to
the report
so in suffolk we have a number of
working group officer working groups
that assist each of those priority areas
and we have a hate crime network which
is a network of officers that
collectively explore and develop new
ways to
of increasing the visibility of hate
crime how it's reported
through
and we support a number sort of national
awareness campaigns um training programs
and projects such as the hope awards
which is supported by the csp
and its partners to celebrate
contributions by young people
in terms of showing real sort of
examples of kindness and determination
in what they do
similarly we have a prevent delivery
group
which is um also supports a lot of the
work in relation to the prevent agenda
and over the last year we've been doing
quite a lot of work around the
development of something called a
situation situational risk assessment
um
and also ongoing uh management of a
prevent action plan
the situational risk assessment every
local authority has a responsibility to
do that we've we've joined forces across
the country to do that collectively
and that's basically setting the scene
and the picture for um baby in
mid-suffolk in terms of the geographical
area the the demographics and the the
communities that make up our uh our two
districts um and the point of that is to
understand what kind of our specific
risks might be
in relation to to prevent
um
we don't have
some big educational facilities like
colleges or universities or we don't and
so other so we don't have as greater
risk as some other areas
but nevertheless we do have a risk
assessment that goes alongside that
particular assessment and we also have a
like i said a prevent action plan which
again all all the districts and boroughs
across the county
are reporting into
as you've already heard we've made
something or giving some considerable
attention to violence against women and
girls priority and notably the
development of a revised ball strategy
currently we're progressing through the
action planning for that strategy and
once that's complete much a lot of that
will form part of the action plan for
the the csp for the next and following
year
contributing to this there is now a new
safe accommodation strategy
the districts have also received funding
towards to support d.a victims
we have a newly appointed dada liaison
officer and we've also established a da
champions officers group that will also
progress and champion a lot of the
actions for the two districts
and that will continue to grow as we get
more and more of our employees trained
and similar to vorg as you've already
heard from councillor mansell we have
the
a new modern slavery strategy
that's now being developed as alongside
its action plan and again that will form
part and parcel of the csp action plan
and that's very closely linked with the
work that we're already doing with
regard to criminal exploitation so there
have been over the last year a number of
uh good pieces of work that's taken
place like i said the report and the
action plan describes that in more
detail
but i would be more than happy to take
any questions
but also we also have superintendent
janine ratten here as well who will be
happy to to take questions as well thank
you
thank you um
on my uh
no
i
think vicky you were going to introduce
uh superintendent janine ratman is that
the case
yeah it was just to introduce janine
ratten and whether or not she had any
further updates so she wanted to raise
it because we'll take all the questions
okay thank you
welcome
superintendent
thank you so give us your
presentation thank you i haven't
actually been asked to give a
presentation so i wasn't expecting to
give one i think um vicki's covered most
of the parts today i'm here to support
vikki as we do in all csp activities to
answer any questions specifically that
um
you know applied to the police's
contributions to the csp
council davis is there anything else
you'd like to add to the
presentation before we go to questions
um no as always vikki's been very
thorough and has covered all the bases
but i will just add
um
what a welcome um janine is to to the
partnership um the
the work that the police do obviously uh
is absolutely vital but more importantly
is the data they provide so we can
actually see the tangible benefits of
the strategies that we've got in place
so um as i say she's been a wonderful
addition
and it's important that the partnerships
all provide this sort of data in this
work so we can
try and keep on top of things as much as
possible
so can i thank councillor davis
councillor mansell
vicki and janine
and um
thank you members uh you can now ask
questions
so i i think we're gonna have a lot of
questions so i better make a note who
comes so councillor hinton first
thank you chair um
it says on page
38 of our reports that
um
the
suffolk
west suffolk uh crime prevention
panel
uh covers a
very large geographic area
it doesn't seem to cover
a great sizable
a sizable chunk of baba
because all the data and all the
information in this report seem to stop
at hadley
and that the east of hadley doesn't seem
to exist
now i know that there are different
police police boundaries across baber's
area
and there is a safer neighborhood team
meeting on wednesday for the hadley east
safer neighborhood team which covers a
bit of mid-suffolk as well as the east
of uh of baba but
it's an area that is neglected by baber
as a council or appears to be simply
because it's left out of everything
we've got cctv now in sudbury and hadley
we've got a report talking about west
suffolk
which ex which
excludes
the east of of uh hadley
is there a
an equivalent group covering the east of
hadley and if so
who is it where do they report and
should this scrutiny committee be
looking at their report to see that the
whole of baber is actually scrutinizing
uh these actions
yeah thank you for your question john it
is something that obviously
being from the uh stunning shortly
beneath myself i'm very keen on making
sure that we are as inclusive as
possible
um
and the importance of the data as has
been mentioned coming into us so we can
use it as wide as possible um
it is exactly that so we do cover so
there is an eastern suffolk community
partnership which covers zip switch and
and feeling stone around that area but
it's it's geographically a little bit
difficult janine is a western commander
but she covers some of the other areas
which cross over so it's not always
entirely
clear so that's something we're looking
to
to change because the name itself
western subject community partnership is
a bit of a misnomer because as you say
it covers sound software it covers all
of baber from shot league to glensford
that covers that whole area um in terms
of the uh
the police say for neighborhood team
the hadley um police team covers the
shotley peninsula covers eastbourgol um
so although it's the hadley safe safe
and neighborhood team it covers a wide
area as well so sometimes the names can
be a bit confusing but the data is there
for for all of the areas so for example
uh the modern slavery data that included
some reports from shotley
beach where there were
a preponderance of
cocker pickers and there was a suspicion
that there were gang masters involved in
that and human slavery and the police
came out and investigated that some of
those figures are included in that or
they may not necessarily say
shortly
so i hope that goes some way to answer
the questions and i don't know uh if the
ad or the superintendent would like to
add to that
nothing further to add
council derek davis is exactly right it
does cover the whole of baber and the
whole of mid-suffolk and all of the
western area
it's it's just the title of the csp but
the data included covers all three
district council areas
yeah
yeah if i could come back because
looking at the report that's been put
into put in front of us
um there's some funny little maps on
one of the sections i'm just trying to
find them there oh here we are at the
back here it's on the overview and
scrutiny report 22 september 21
you look at the lines there
on that map
on page 65 and on
page 67
they certainly do not include the area
east of hadley
in actual fact one doesn't even include
hadley
so if they are that's the statistical
base for that it means that there's a
great chunk of baby where statistically
it is not represented at all
so if we're going by these sorts of
reports
they're misleading us because they're
not actually doing what's supposed to do
we can see from the
where are we page 38
paragraph 4.4
ipsic and east suffolk
east community commission
clinical commissioning group are
represented on the on your panel
they cover that
clinical commissioning group also
includes colchester hospital
sorry i mean and it's we are we have a
medley of different um you're absolutely
right different kind of uh maps and
boundaries that we have to work with in
terms with our colleagues from
institution a ccg in the west ccg
the report that you're referring to on
page 64 65 where you got those
boundaries that was a separate report on
asb that came to open the scrutiny
committee last year where we were
reporting on the progress that we'd made
with regards to
asb and
in terms of the the maps that we were
showing there we were kind of
highlighting some of the hot spots for
asb so those are kind of what we've
designed there is more the map around
where some of the hot spots are not
necessarily the boundaries for the csp
partnership so it was it's a separate
report where we came to even scrutiny
committee to update on where um like say
hot spots for any social behavior were
taking place so they're just so that's
hot spot area not the csp area
so do your question
[Music]
a little bit more confusing it obviously
means that certain items cover different
areas which makes the whole thing the
whole picture even more complicated and
and even more if you like less inclusive
because when you're looking at modern
slavery and all those sorts of things
who on earth do the people in my ward
for instance in east berkhold
report those sort of instances too
because there's no police station at
cable anymore that's not manned
the hadley one's barely manned
but according to this report
we're not covered by anybody
perhaps we should go to essex i know
there's been proposals in the past for
east berkeley parish to be taken out of
suffolk and put into essex counselling
better treatment but um you're bordering
into debate
yeah so
to to answer that directly um
it's it's like any reporting in a
village everything either 101 or use the
online reporting tool and then the
police will then um send the appropriate
officers to deal with that i'm not
wanting to take janine's
thing here but
because i've done it myself so it's not
about whether it's the western soviet
community safety partnership dealing
specifically with a village because it
is the wide area as they say you know it
goes from berries and edmonds all of the
mid-soviet water baby so but the data
comes back to us
for for the whole area and and and for
you if you you know if you've got
someone in uh is bergot concerned about
whatever type of human slavery or
domestic
violence against women and girls then
then you report it in the normal matter
to the police
can i um just ask
superintendent janine
to uh
give her a view on this thank you to you
i think it's very important the
boundaries to work with i am the west
area commander i'm also the force lead
for all of asb all of rural crime all of
licensings our boundaries are not quite
as definitive as they perhaps are with
council district councils it could be my
officer hadley i quite often work at
hadley police station because i live in
essex i travel there so i go there quite
often we aren't quite as bound by
boundaries in policing as we are if you
phone into 101 you'll get the nerve
nearest best available officer to come
and take that report they're all trained
in hate crime they're all trained in
modern slavery you'll get an appropriate
response wherever you are to whatever
you report to us the statistics are a
bit difficult because the reporting
system because of the boundaries so it
is hard and we can look at how we look
at different statistic reporting that we
give you in the figures we give you that
is something we can you know take away
and vicky and i have already had quite a
few discussions about how we're going to
make that better going forward and but
as to who they report to it should make
no
difference we are very clean to
most superintendents and above have
thematic responsibilities across the
whole of the contemporary so i will make
sure that the east suffolk gets the same
service as westers and south
you know we all care for the areas that
we lead in and it wouldn't matter what
area when you still get the right
response
thank you ginny
councillor hinton it might be something
that we need to pursue outside of this
meeting and or request some information
that you feel is missing would that be
more helpful to you
well i think it's it's fairly clear in
the report that the statistics in there
are
extrapolated from national
crime surveys etc so it's dip pin them
down but we haven't had really had an
answer as to whether or not
east of hadley should be
part of his part of the east suffolk
yeah well as a ward member of the east
of hudley i think all of us including
the cabinet member
we we are
interested at so we may look at that as
a piece of information that could come
back to this committee
uh kathy you wanted to say
could i just ask um vicky mosley to
reconfirm the bindery of the west
partnership
yeah so the western partnership so the
western suffolk csp includes the whole
of west council boundary baber and
mid-suffolk so it's the whole of those
three councils boundaries that form the
western suffolk csp
thank you vicky
and so counselor scarf is next with a
question
uh thank you i've got um
two questions actually but um i'll ask
them and perhaps we can get an answer to
the first one um i think the first one
is probably really easy to deal with um
page 46 refers to part of the modern
slavery um
element and it talks about the
responsible car wash scheme um i'm quite
interested in this because the project
is successful will give
our residents the confidence that
the car washes that they use are not
being run by
exploitation
the pilot project is going to
award a responsible cargo scheme
approved status and publicize this and
um posters and billboards will be
displayed in the various towns uh to
illustrate that um i'm wondering if
that has actually taken into account
that in fact
one of the things that turns over the
most in terms of ownership of car washes
is the very fact that they change all of
the time any car wash you see i mean i
can see them in stone market goes under
new ownership
so having awarded the status you're
confident that
that car wash at that time with that
management had the necessary credentials
how will the scheme ensure that a new
ownership of a car wash
is then reinspected and doesn't use the
existing signage
can i ask who's going to answer that
i'll answer that chair um
it is a moving feast it's not the quite
the same as other things under licensing
where they have to apply for a license
so it is a harder thing to monitor what
will be happening will the safer
neighbours teams will be aware of this
scheme and you won't be surprised to
know that car washes is venues they
visit quite often because there is the
possibility of modern slavery happening
there so as soon as they notice that
there's a change in management just
doing good old-fashioned police work
then they can report it and we can go
through the scheme schemes actually
owned by colleagues in cid because
obviously modern slavery do it's quite
serious investigation they own it um but
the ground work is done by officers
boots on the floor and also something
that we'd ask for communities and
councillors like yourselves to let us
know if you've noticed a change because
more intelligence we get in the more
quick we can act on it
counselor
do you want to come back with yourself
thank you thank you for that
that's very useful to know i mean it's
just something that needs to be on the
radar um the second question was on
page 53 we've got the west suffolk csp
action plan
starting on page 53
there are a number because of the
traffic light system with the current
status it draws your eye to those that
have not made
progress so far
and i wondered if perhaps we could have
a little bit more information about the
prevent strategy in regards to ensuring
that community-based organizations and
community leaders have prevent awareness
is there an update that perhaps the
committee could have today
on that particular subject thank you
uh thank you for that in terms of you're
absolutely right that we like to use the
the traffic light system and what we've
also introduced in this last quarter is
a direction of travel as well so we can
see where we've tried to make some
improvements with regard to to prevent
and at the csp in the last quarter um
that exact same question was also raised
and so in this previous quarter that
we've just gone through we have moved
some of those reds into the ambers where
we've tried to do a lot more work and
like i've said we've progressed a lot
more on the prevent
action plan which is led by an officer
group and
that would then feed into the csp but
also we've
progressed our situational risk
assessment a lot more as well some of
the work that where we've been held up
has been around working with our
community groups going working with
parish councils
and providing sort of uh training
and development and awareness so that's
something that we still need to progress
and we understand what that needs to
look like because we've been supporting
those community groups too to reopen we
haven't actually delivered on some of
those activities but that will be
something that we complete for
22-23
an additional piece of work that we
launched just a couple of weeks ago was
our prevent week of action as well where
we delivered some training to both um
there was online training which was open
and available to members of the public
and that was shared wider and also to
councillors and also
to professional groups as well so we
have made
significant improvements and changes in
the last quarter towards that prevent
agenda both with awareness raising but
also some of our kind of harder
action plans and risk assessments as
well
mr scarf does that answer your question
that's fine that's very helpful actually
to know thank you
yes thank you
um
it must be a part a deficit in my uh
attention i came here with a very clear
idea of what's the
western suffolk yes i've got it right uh
csp did nazmus meetings gone on i've got
myself thoroughly confused um
i say there's an area where you're doing
training part of it is where you're
collecting data and uh statistics
um and i'm extremely grateful for the
area commander i don't know the correct
title to use it
for your talk technique clear up but um
so
the whole of suffolk is covered and it
doesn't matter which who you report it
to you and you get the same thing but it
would help for us when we get reports
based on the statistics
if we could have
geographical
boundaries of showing what department
does this what department does
that's what
on paper
on page of paper so we can actually see
this for ourselves rather than being
told when reading about it been getting
different
um there's part of this report that
um states about what the western suffolk
is doing part of it states what scc and
part of what mid-suffolk is doing
and i realized that
it's
you
communicate within it with each other
but
as the majority of it seems to be doing
by western suffolk some of it's by
mittovic is there more that mid suffolk
should be doing to pick up one and
rather than just relying solely on the
western suffolk
to do
and
basically well yeah basically like what
should we be doing more
rather than relying on a partnership
which is brilliant to have one we need
to have but should we be picking up more
to do
um yeah
and
i have to admit i'm not a big fan of um
of the name western suffer because it
does confuse the life of me and everyone
else so i totally take that on board and
perhaps i can suggest i did certainly
try and suggest it before that we
changed the name um didn't get very far
but i'll give it another go but to
answer your question it's not
specifically that what mid suffolk can
do more or babe or even um west suffolk
it's
the partnership working together with
the officers to provide um awareness
training
as much as anything else for example
with the prevent as vicky's already
mentioned um and
and i hate to use the word pre-pandemic
but before uh before
that horrible outbreak our officers were
delivering some great training in terms
of um
hate crime
the awareness and i'm sure many of the
counselors here have been to some of
those sessions and they were very useful
and i think that's something that
will be picked up again um how how we do
that is whether it's um
in person or virtual but they are the
sort of things that our officers are
putting together um and you'll see
things like the white ribbon campaign
that um france team's been at the the
forefront for and it's things like that
as a partnership that we can do i won't
even say western suffolk partnership but
the csp can do yeah
i hope that answers your question
sufficiently
yeah okay thanks
councilcaster do you have another
question
we can go to so i'll go i'll come back
to you okay
thank you chad i've got i've got quite a
series of questions
um
the first the first is about vorg
whenever we talk about vorg at the
police and crime panel
um
the pcc always says
vogue including men and boys so when
you're talking about vorg are you
including men and boys
um and
and also
uh the other question about uh
vorg is is there emergency accommodation
is there sufficient emergency
accommodation for people who have to be
removed to a safe place
um
in short
yes
and again the title is not great because
it it does disguise it but it's
something that certainly has been
brought up i've brought it up and other
members brought up about men and boys as
well
in terms of the accommodation i don't
know specifically the answer however at
last weeks or the week before health and
well being board i asked the same
question um at that meeting and i was
assured that um there were enough
emergency accommodation um and and
within the suffolk area so it didn't
have to go out um
and
sort of less specifically um
regarding those just children who were
being traumatized and
um
the incidents that they were going
through were being dealt with usually
through um short term fostering and then
moving on from there i don't know the
specific i was told the the number of
accommodation that we had i can't
remember the figure off the top of my
head but if it's something that you'd
like us to get back to you on i'm sure
we can unless wiki or yeah
not necessarily a specific answer now
but i i have when i asked a question
once before there were there was
accommodation for
women or families led by the
the female
but the real problem was finding
accommodation for um
men with a family or for young males
sort of late to late teens upwards sort
of uh asia and at that time i believe
that there was no accommodation
certainly none in mid-suffolk
i don't know about suffolk at all so if
yeah if somebody could look into that
that that would be great
um one one one other thing is that
as i see it
the partnership
uh there are lots of bodies within the
partnership
does the partnership actually have funds
that the partnership spends on
um projects
or
is the
funding
coming from
the constituent parts of
the um the partnership for instance baba
district council and mid-suffolk
district council if that is the case
is there a problem over funding in some
parts of
some areas within the partnership area
it's pretty clear that the
mid-suffolk
finances are in a slightly different
position to the labor finances and
possibly there are other
other districts within suffolk who have
well i guess they can't different
priorities because the priorities are
agreed
at the partnership meetings
but the ability to meet those priorities
may be different in different parts of
the county
is that is that the case
yeah in terms of the the uh the
partnership itself there are modest
funds that are that the partnership has
to allocate out to support projects so
um both baber and miss suffolk and
western uh suffolk and the county
council or contribute to create a csp
budget if you like and then dependent on
where the needs are and where um
officers then work with particular some
community groups then those community
groups can then bid into the csp to
apply for funding to deliver
youth programs so for example we've
worked um
with projects in babylon projects in
mid-suffolk mid-suffolk we've recently
supported them with an allocation of i
think seven thousand pounds to provide
youth projects so to support our
criminal exploitation activities to
actually create those die sort of
diversionary activities to within that
kind of space in the evenings where
where kids might be loitering in sort of
and creating asp but actually they're at
risk of being exploited by other groups
so we've supported groups
where they've um where they've applied
for funding so there is
adequate funding within the csb it
hasn't all been spent and often there
was a carry forward into the next year
so i wouldn't say so i would say that
where where um projects that been found
and identified again bellevue we've been
working with active suffolk and the
police with projects to deliver um with
young people in bellevue park where
there was high degrees of asb so where
we've identified issues we've looked to
support community groups to create
projects and they've received funding
from the csp to do that yeah
sorry if i'm
asking the questions but one of one of
my concerns was around the diversionary
tactics if i can call them diversity
tactics and the safe places scheme
project 13 is to do with the safe places
scheme and it seems to have been delayed
is it a high priority
and where will the funding for it come
from
yeah the same spaces scheme is something
which the county council were leading on
and i have so i won't be able to and i'm
not able to provide a comment on that i
can find out for you but that has been
delayed for quite some some time
it just hasn't been the key priority for
the partnership it's moved on
on all other
fronts as you can see from the action
plan but not that particular initiative
so i'll have to speak to the county
council as to why that hasn't progressed
um could i could i ask a question having
heard that that answer vicki can ask the
question of the uh of the police officer
the commander
do you think say the safe places scheme
is something which is which is a high
priority ought to be a high priority in
ought to be funded because it seems to
me that if some if some of these young
people need to get away from where they
are they need somewhere to go to
and and this
would help
i think it is anything that puts our
young people into a safe space to be
able to avoid criminal exploitation asb
exposure to those things is good the
only thing i'd say with all this project
is that they need a proper evaluation
because
in some areas they don't attract the
right kids kids that go to these sort of
places will be kids that are already
quite easy to engage with so it's just
it needs to be evaluated to make sure
you are attracting and reaching out to
the right cohort of people to show that
you are really making a difference
thank you um
can i carry on or should i start
do you want to give somebody else a
chance shall we um give some other
i mean we're going to go on with a lot
of questions shall we give some other
members the opportunity
thank you madam chairman um
looking at appendix 2
page 57
um we have a couple of charts there
um
[Music]
the first chart really looks at a year
snapshot of the different types of crime
and we can see
that uh violence and sexual offenses are
the highest uh
crime type
according to that chart followed closely
were not followed closely but certainly
followed by criminal damage and arson
and if we look at the
the graph below it which charts the
monthly crime rate
over the last uh two years so 2020 and
2021
um really at a glance one can
say that
there's not been a huge change in the
crime rate and i just like to understand
uh what is being done to actually drive
the crime rate down from that level
um
and in particular
i'd like to understand what we're doing
in in relation to the violence and
sexual offenses because i see a lot of
information in here about asb
and if i look at the chart on page 58
thankfully we see a decline in asb and
if you look at the
asb rates versus the rest of the crime
rate and asb is in fact a relatively
small percentage of the overall crime
rate so i'd like to understand what
we're doing
about the other crimes particularly the
violence and sexual offences crimes
so um
you'll be not surprised to hear the
force looks at performance very closely
on a monthly basis what we do is we work
on a long-term average and look up for
exceptions to see where we've got an
increase
actually um
covid has um probably quite slightly
skewed figures and it's actually hard to
sometimes see where your upper
expectations are
there has been an increase in violence
and sexual offences because they went so
low over the period of the pandemic so
it will look like a slightly unnatural
increase but actually if you look at
pre-figures
they're back on par and if we compare
ourselves to what we do is compare
ourselves it's called most similar
groups so we look at other forces with
the same sort of number of populations
and crime types we are quite low if you
look at
suffix comes out well on performance
figures the one thing i'd say about asb
is asb has been under reported um
over the last few years so as bigger
figures aren't probably showing as they
should and i know that as the head of
asb and i know that we need to do a lot
of work on giving people confidence and
reporting and the way we report it the
other thing i'd say about asp is it's an
important thing to focus on because if
you look at people's criminal histories
i'd say most people are involved in
violent crime probably started with some
sort of asb i wouldn't go so far say
gateway but it is in some cases and
actually especially our youths if we
tackle that early on that is something
we can do about stopping violent crime
from the further later down stages so
both things are really important to
focus on um violence we do do mapping
exactly where we go we have specific
plans and i know exactly in my areas
where i have
increases in violence and i will make a
plan and have a task in to deal with
that
does that answer your question
counsellor
funnehal thank you very
much i'm just going to intersperse the
questionnaire
council barrick you're the next one okay
but i've got this question that was uh
i'm asking it on behalf of council lee
jamison who raised our
district council meeting
and so
i'll just intersperse that now
he was asking about the records and
evidence of the effectiveness of the cct
the installations at sabrin hadley
and his question is
um
have they made a difference i know it's
um i've read the
report but i think for the record i
think i would like him to have that
answered thank you
in relation to the cctv
report at the moment this it's still
very very early days in terms of whether
or not they
have been effective we do have reports
that show um the number of uh
the the the reports that we made by the
cctv cameras and the number of those
that have led to arrests so i can share
those i don't have those figures off the
top of my head but they are showing at
the moment that just by the use of the
cctv cameras they have led to a number
of rest in a number of areas where we've
used hotspot cameras as well so mobile
cameras
we have and i think there was a bus
shelter that i refer to in the the
report again we've shown that that
continuous sort of persistent asb
behavior has now ceased to to exist so
we will look to see and disperse that
particular camera somewhere else where
there'll be a hotspot it'll obviously be
interesting to know whether we've just
dispersed that asb behavior and has gone
somewhere else or not but i think that's
where we'll keep a close eye on so we
will get regular reports we are um we'll
get quarterly reports from the for the
ctt cameras and we do have regular
meetings with the operators as well in
terms of looking at sort of trends and
asking and asking them to support us
with things like um vogue so
understanding where there might be some
quiet spots where they might want to
monitor where
particular types of violent crime might
take place so
i think it's just too early to report on
that at the moment but we but we will do
vicky
and and chair if i could just um draw
the meeting's attention to paragraph
8.55 of the report
where
regarding hadley and sudbury
since the installation of the upgraded
cctv
96 incidents have been recorded across
both times and that has led to 43
arrests
thank you i was i mean i read that in
the report
but
what i was going to do was then send
that information to councillor jameson
as he asked that question specifically
thank you very much
councillor barrett
thank you very much
excuse me um i just wanted to ask a
little bit about
the clarity of pathways for dealing with
violence against women and
domestic abuse
because reading the
report
and looking at the complexity of some of
the bodies the steering group the
partnership the board the action plan
it's quite baffling
for from an outsider and i wondered
about internally in the actual
service that where you would you're
dealing with these what is it like as a
as an officer who gets a report and is
trying to
steer their way through this
is there a very clear route through all
that or is it quite you know is it quite
has it been developed quite piecemeal
because of different things that
happened or is it is there a
you know is there is there um
efficiency of of the process really
and from the policing perspective uh i
think uh my level is quite not confusing
there's a lot to read we've got the
national police uh two councils vogue
strategy there's the now the suffolk
joint strategy and there's a lot to take
in all all much needed all of it
appropriate you know required for my
staff they don't need to have that they
don't need that detail so in my area in
the west area i have a westborg strategy
and it's broken down into their bespoke
actions in each area
giving them the clear directions of what
they need to do for me to be able to
satisfy that i'm achieving those
strategies so internally we do simplify
it i'm not you know suggesting that my
officers wouldn't be able to understand
they just don't have the capacity to do
there's so many strategies and that's
what my job is to simplify and give
clear direction to what they're expected
so i would say if you spoke to an
officer on the street about their
expectations around vorg they would be
very clear and know what they need to do
domestic abuse um
i think it's understood that um victims
of uh often don't
take any action until they've been
assaulted about 30 times that is that
about right
um
but obviously they could be in the
household where children are present
during those attacks
um
is is is um
is there some close working with the
other agencies in those situations to
safeguard those children
because the you know the damage is being
done isn't it
um
and um is there what sort of
what's the arrangement with the
the parent who's perhaps
not taking action to safeguard their own
children in that situation there's a
delicate balance i don't understand but
how does that how does that work
there's three parts i'd like to focus on
because there's loads of work that takes
that place the first one is the new
thing of the voice of the child um it's
something that's been around for years
and years but suffolk constabulary this
year have put a real focus on it so when
we attend domestic violence when we
attend any sort of
crime in the home where children's
present we speak to the children we get
their views or if they're too young
you use your professional judgment to do
that we then work with the within the
mesh environment multi-agency
safeguarding hub where all agencies work
together to come up with a plan to you
know address those issues together
because that is something especially
when it comes to children young people
you can't do in isolation the other bit
i would say is it does take sometimes
some victims of crime domestic crime to
report and and we have over the last few
years have been quite a few more orders
that have come into force that we can
use domestic violence protection orders
stalking protection orders and they are
being used much more widely over the
last few years the knowledge around them
has come in so when a victim comes in
that they'll be there for that victim
who doesn't want to procrastinate to
leave someone who's been abusing for
years and we sort of almost take the
decision at their hand for a short while
to give us space to get other agencies
to work with them to say to them you can
break the cycle of violence and to do it
and i'm you know i'm proud to say that i
get officers approach me nearly daily to
sign off those sort of orders now
because we are thinking of we don't just
go they're not willing anymore they're
not you know they're not given a
statement we do give people that space
and work with our agencies to try and
tackle that
thank you
to everybody because there are still a
lot of questions to come from the
committee but i'm going to go to the two
members who actually haven't asked a
question
yet so uh counselor custom please
thank you very much madam chairman
um
with this looking at this report um
obviously i've seen a few of these
reports now
and i realized what a change in
landscape
it is it's very different from the last
report um you i
i can't remember it exactly but it seems
like there's maybe less drugs
more
violence there's some
there seems to be less cuckoo in there
seems to be one
um
cuckoo in um
crime reported
on there for the anti-social behavior um
how does the partnership
stay ahead of this changing
landscape it's i assume it's
mainly police driven but i might be
wrong
about that because um
you know there's some
there's ever such a lot of um
there's ever such a lot of things going
on
um how do you stay on top of that and
i've got a um i've got a second question
please if i might ask that afterwards
who's setting the agenda for the
partnership is a very simple way of
asking that question
i think um
every year we undertake a strategic
assessment so like i said before so
suffolk county council are leading on
that for all csps across the county at
the moment so if there's csp and east
suffolk csp and the western suburbs csp
are all having something called a
strategic assessment where there will be
kind of those kind of softer
conversations taking place with each of
the partners what they are experiencing
what they're seeing whether that's from
a health perspective an education
perspective what they are seeing within
their kind of their their
those spaces that they work within the
other piece of work that they are um
that the county council are collecting
at the moment is working very closely
like you say with with the police as
well in terms of getting a lot of that
statistical information in
um and so
we know even though we haven't received
the the assessment from the strategic
assessment as yet we know that through
conversations that we're having with
those officers at the county council who
are doing that work that actually there
has been um an increase in fortuna you
know um i.t
online fraud activity particularly in
the county and actually if you were to
take away the inc the
increasing crime on fraud all other
crime and hopefully i'm not out lying
when i say this is that
all other crimes are reduced by 14 but
because of the increase in fraud crime
um our figures have continued to go uh
on an upward direction
trajectory um so so that's where we keep
ahead of the game so we we have those
strategic assessments each year um
also
uh janine ratten brings to the asb csp
partnership all asb and other type crime
performance information so we can see
that direction of travel as well and if
the committee or the partnership
chooses to respond to some of that
that's where it'll have its discussions
around that so primarily i would say
that the strategic assessment but then
the court information then also that
comes to the csp
yes um
i just add as well we do all that but on
a tactical level i actually um
i chair monthly my area a tactical
tasking and coordination group where i
look monthly exactly what is going on my
areas and i um since i've been in post
i've invited members from all district
councils of the areas i cover to attend
that meeting and that's based on
statistics crime rates for that month
month on month and they will hear what i
am saying that i want to be focused on
that month what type tax revenues and
they contribute and say how they can
work together on it so
it's great we do it cause it's great but
actually in the west we're doing it
monthly and so they are in the weeds
that when changes happen they know
almost immediately and so we are really
on the forefront we're doing that
another question
oh
sorry derrick councillor davis yeah
thanks uh to to answer specifically for
for the partnership um
it's good to hear that you've said that
there's a change in the landscape
because you know and that is driven by
the data we received and and personally
i think that the data has got better i
think the nc system that we now have
helps us with that but even so we're
still a little bit on the drag in terms
of things that are happening and you
mentioned about cuckoo in the county
lines um you just have to read um you
know the press or the people watch the
bbc to see
you know the amazing work that the
police have done in our county to stop
that they're working very closely with
the met and other places so by the time
the report comes around again it will
look um different and and hopefully um
more encouraging as
well uh councillor osborne you had a
question oh have you got sorry sorry
sorry i do have a supplement through
this question but um yeah thank you very
much that was a really um really good
answer i got there um
with the um where
begging
is considered
and the anti-social behavior which i
believe it is in this um report
um
how is it dealt with as um
is it considered a
criminal offense or
and um where does the uh well it
obviously is but is it dealt with as a
criminal act and where does
mid suffolk and obviously baby's
homelessness prevention team
fit in with that when um i i don't know
if there's any cases of
um begging being reported as a
anti-social um
as anti-social behavior is that because
it's been dealt with outside of
criminal prosecution or
however however you'd deal with it
so begging is an offense it's not just
begging he has to be aggressive and
persistent it's a specific crime type
and there's other conditions to it it's
not just someone sitting quietly with a
you know a bowles or quest in it um
it's not we if you need to deal with it
like that we would but in most cases a
more restorative way of dealing with it
working with our partners and homeless
you know finding out the reasons why
they're begging because actually
normally you can deal with it if they've
got a real reason to beg they're going
to beg again next week and keep on doing
it so it's not a
it's not an effective way to deal with
it long term and so the officers would
tend to not probably report it as a
crime they may put it on a crime but
wouldn't deal with it as an offence as
in given a sanction like that they would
deal with it in a restorative manner
hey councillor
yeah i think that um
yeah that does i think it's obvious
where our homeless prevention team fit
in and everywhere everything with that
so thank you very much
yeah thank you madam chairman i'd just
like to
just get back to the cctv
obviously being in sudbury
um i have been to the monitoring area in
in west
west south at paris lebanon
and found it exceptional so
i'd just like to give a very big thank
you to
derrick davis for his efforts in getting
that cctv and i think it's a really good
good position
i'd also um just like to
ask the question uh the hot spots in in
sudbury
uh are on we're on two major areas
that's minimum cavernish and bellevue
park
uh although it does drift around
um so
getting back to um kathy nixon's and
vicky's comments i just
just like to know whether
with the cctv whether the amount of uh
crimes that were occurring in these
areas
um
is there a
is it could she just clarify
on those particular areas
has have the numbers gone down and have
we been able to um improve uh on on
those sort of
positions uh possibly one for i've just
got a one question to come back to if i
may uh which i'd like to ask the
um police if i may thank you
yeah thank you in terms of the the
report it shows that there was a decline
of almost 100 crimes in those those hot
spot areas
since that report was written i don't
have an up-to-date figure but i can find
that out for you and report back but
yeah but hopefully we'll continue to
reduce those crime figures
thank you
thank you very much um
just the other question which is related
to cctv
i know the town council have had
various positions on on the crime in
those areas but
we have found that
to get things done
um from the police perspective
it is it is difficult for them to
actually um
uh
be able to uh bring forward what
we've got to go through a lot of hoops
it seems to me that we have got an area
where we could improve on that
and just getting back to uh
councillor
james here
with the
position of begging we have had begging
in
in sudbury quite quite frequently and
although uh the homeless team have
given homes to those people that are
begging they are still out there doing
it so that's just my question
uh all i'd ask is if you that is
continuing if we've got someone's been
homed and they're still doing it then
there are other ways we can do um
criminal behavior orders you know
there's lots of other orders and powers
you can do it rest probably won't still
be the right way but we could look at um
conditions linked to their tendencies
there's lots of other things but we just
need to let you know
some of them do take a long time i'm not
going to
you know be false and say that is not
the case but if you give us the
information i can't sort of without
knowing specific incidents but i'll be
happy to look into it for you
it does seem that
to get answers
uh that we that
particularly the town council want to
know is that there does seem to be
an area where
we don't get the answers that we're
looking for and it comes up regularly at
our full council meetings so
if there are aspects that we could
improve on
could we have a look at that please of
course yeah
okay
before i move on to the second wave of
questions i've got you all in orders i
haven't forgotten that i'm going to ask
one for myself actually
um
as chair it's um a bit difficult to
there's so many questions this morning
and that's good
given the example of the stella maris
problem
in terms of the
csp
where where does the responsibility lie
should something untoward happen within
that network
who's going to
you know carry the can really if
something goes radically wrong with the
partnership
thank you yeah um
yeah thanks it's a good question um the
the partnership obviously over overseas
and has the strategy to look over over
those uh whole thing but as you will
have seen by the stereo marius report
the partnership working is so vital and
the fact that there wasn't
as good a joined up working together
previously
as it could have been and should have
been i think the report highlighted the
deficiencies i think the actions that
have been taken subsequently
show um that
everything is being dealt with so all
the 32 recommendations you know i think
there's all bar 10 that have actually
been implemented and the rest have been
working on as you say
um the actual responsibility obviously
because stella maris for example was in
baber and if it's within paper then it's
our responsibility
what's been mentioned in in the
introduction as well as the community
trigger points so it's important that we
find these things early we can uh
action the community trigger point and
and we can take that forward
and obviously if there were
a similar situation uh with assisted
living accommodation say in mid
southwark or in west of it again the
district council would pick that up and
the community safety partnership would
have an overview
and looking at that
exactly thank you councillor davis
councillor carter you're the top of the
list
thank you i'm afraid i've actually got
three questions i don't know but you
should say asking separately or ask them
once
let's go at once
okay um my first question is i assure
you a concern and
we have a support which is somewhat
reassuring but i am aware there is a
plague of under-reporting
um especially in my wards the lack of
well we have quite a bit of police but
while residents feel there's a lack of
police
presence
um they've stopped reporting drug
dealing which is going on
because without the
waiting queues of the phone line
they say by the time they've got hold of
somebody they've either moved on or
they're told there's going to be too
long and wait
so they most of the rejections have
stopped calling
and the lack of police presence
overall
it has been felt on other wards as well
but i'm aware of
and things like um because they feel if
they report break-ins they're told
unless there's somebody in the house
police aren't going to come out for a
few days later what's the point in
gordon
so that is
unfortunately something i hear quite
regularly
um
[Music]
how what can be done about this i'm
assuming some of it is due to
lack of funding some of it is due to
lack of police numbers
but
how are we going to
how are we going to solve the
underreporting and how we're going to
make residents feel more reassured
and what they're calling especially
something can be done about
did you want to answer this first or
should i go to the next questions
i'll just briefly answer that before i
pass it on to janine um
in my experience now and obviously this
is not specifically csp but in my
experience in my ward i found that the
best and easiest way is to use the
online reporting tool subject police
have got a website and it's very
reactive and and i know it's monitored
i've i've used it with my in my own
experiences
passing on problems from from residents
and i totally agree about 101 it's not
the best and it does take a long time
but the online reporting tool i'm
probably going to get it swamped now but
it's an excellent tool and to please
pick it up very very quickly i mean i've
literally had officers out within an
hour or so dealing with
relatively minor um dealings um
especially war crime and things like
that so
if you get a resident saying that then i
would urge them to go to the it's really
easy to find it's really easy to to fill
the form in as well so that's my
personal experience as a ward member
and janine will probably give you the
rest about resources
so resources are always a challenge um
a lot of people will say we have to do
more with less now and our numbers are
actually okay but we crimes are more
complex now they take longer if you
think about modern slavery or vorg you
know
we're not hopping from one call to the
next most the time we'll respond to
calls we're not that visible because
we're in people's homes
i'd love to say i could put officers out
patrolling like i
in the good old days and i was waiting
we did we just probably don't have the
capacity to do that i think what we all
need to do is educate our communities
and our members to understand that an
officer responding
isn't to be on the end of you reporting
i told you a little while ago about my
tactical tasking coordinating group
based on statistics and hot spots so if
someone in an area if 10 people phone in
and say there's drugs even if we didn't
manage to get there at the time i know
there's an issue
and so then i will put resources into
that they'll probably be playing close
resources that of your communities may
not know are there but we can share the
good news afterwards and we can do a lot
more of media i would encourage your
communities to look on our social media
pages i'm quite
i enjoy following myself because we do
share the good news we do and a lot of
it will have been probably without
people being aware we're doing that but
they need to know a burglary yet we
don't
unfortunately always come out straight
away there's no one you know forensics
will come out straight away and we'll go
and do house to house but we still need
to know that information because if
there is someone we can link it to if
it's a certain
mo
that we know we could probably get a
suspect very quickly it's not always
about the attendance and i know it's a
change of mindset for people and i'd
love to say especially some of our more
vulnerable communities i'd love to send
someone to them every time but actually
sometimes it's more important for me to
send them to where i know the
corporate perpetrator is to deal with
this situation to make sure we don't
have a second victim
thank you um i would say with the online
tool um not much use if you're on a
mobile phone or if you haven't got
internet so um but
anyway um all that intelligence helps
the police has just been sort of
outlined so even if he went to get home
to do it or whatever but yeah
certainly
um
the other question i had um
well we've
talked about
vogue again
another thing that's
widely under reported is
just abuse against children
and doesn't matter if it's
women
boys
girls
it's
vines full stop should be a priority and
it'd be wonderful
i kind of i'm concerned that
vorg as a focus
distracts somewhat away from what
something we
awareness needs to be built
we do have issues with coercive control
of partners where
the
partner will abuse the child and it
won't be
reported by other person in control
we have issues where one of the parents
is
unable to protect the child for whatever
reason and abuse from from a second part
so we
i would be
mindful of what we can do to promote
this and to actually uh
how we can
solve the under reporting issue
i'm aware it certainly went on when it
happened to me
it'd be nice to know that it doesn't
still happen
now which unfortunately i'm hearing the
cases
repeatedly
so
[Music]
that's one of the questions
yeah did you want to answer
i can only agree with your sentiments as
a mother of two young children myself i
wish we could completely eradicate
violence against children the voice of
the child has been an important
change because part of is reminding
officers to think about the voice that
can't be heard
you know because both parents might not
be if the mother or father of a victim
they might not always be thinking about
a child we do rely heavily on partners
we have great relationships with our
schools because that is a real
opportunity for us to get information
that we might not always get when we go
into the school so
i can honestly think most police
officers would completely agree with the
sentiment as well so it is about
reminding us and it is sort of thinking
just because someone in the room is not
the person we're talking to it's you
know voice of the child isn't just about
it's not the literal voice of the child
it's thinking right what does that child
just seen
how could that affected them
you know it is about speaking to them if
they're able to talk to you it's about
saying to you has affected you what else
have you seen and making sure they are
heard wherever possible
thank you i'm afraid
my concern is how do we get that
reported to you in the first place if
you're not thought if it's not reports
on violence of a partner
so we do work in schools but what
happens when it's not reported to a
school or
not how do we get people to report
how do we get neighbours to
because if they report they might turn
out and might turn around and say
well we're not going to interfere this
is it might be a naughty child that's
being told off but how do we build
awareness how do we get this
a very
easy to hide subject
how do we get it from under the carpet
i think we also just always have to
encourage people to report it there are
ways they can report if they want to
anonymously find crime stoppers and that
we understand it's a hard thing to do
every call will be followed up if
someone's got concerns about a child
we'd always attend
yes it might not always be no but that
child will be on the system then it will
go to a match referral to other agents
just to see if they have anything
similar we do tie up and make sure we
try and all the links i'd love to say
that we wouldn't miss anything but
i suppose it's encouraging people to
have that voice and you know
as many voices as possible to let us
know but we would follow up on
everything we're told
that there is a television campaign at
the moment
encouraging people to do exactly as
janine has just said you know the
neighbors if they're not sure to report
it
and that to television campaign has been
shared widely on social media as well
and again it's about as you said earlier
it's about educating the community and
it's about um changing the mindset
because obviously we know that there are
some communities where people will just
keep their heads down and and not do
anything but all all that sort of um
promotion on on both television and
social media can help get that and the
other thing that just going to the um
csp one of the um the the the
the data that came back is it's not just
um violence against children which of
course is abhorrent
but um during the pandemic there were
incidents or an increase in numbers and
i think janine might have the actual
figures maybe not to hand of children
attacking parents and grandparents out
of sheer frustration um and and other
problems so that sort of thing that we
can drill down there's that data we can
draw down to and obviously
all the partnership agencies within the
csp can be aware of that and be able to
be mindful about how to deal with that
has that answered all your questions
counselor carter
very quickly because kathy nixon wants
to say something okay
shall i
if i could just come back on your um
question in relation to um awareness um
you know an identification of the abuse
of children i'm a member of the suffolk
children's safeguarding partnership
board and
that
involves
all the statutory agencies and also a
wide range of voluntary and community
agencies
and and through that body we do roll out
a lot of awareness raising and training
for um you know members of those groups
in the partnership um to
promote absolutely what you say and you
know the identification and
the signs to look out for in terms of um
you know safety issues or abuse of
children
thank you that's definitely um given me
to
to
pick up on the social media campaign
more and to reach out to you
um
the final what question i did have
another one but i'm good
being a rural area
it was interesting to hear about the
use of mobile cameras
would it be possible to i know it's been
used in towns could we be using more for
mobile cameras in our more rural
locations
to deal with fly tipping or for
hair coursing things like that which
these may seem like
small issues but the majority of them
are linked to wider enterprises
there is a threshold that needs to be
met for in order to have those um
cameras deployed i mean there's a number
of sort of kind of safeguarding checks
as well in terms of where they go so
that we don't impinge on other people's
privacies as well so i think we'd have
to look at each case individually and
look to see if that may measure the the
threshold in terms of deploying those um
those cameras but yes they it it depends
on the level of activity and uh and
the impact it's having i would say so
it's not a standard yes we can do that
we would need to look very clear clearly
at that particular case
and just to say for those of us crown
types you just mentioned and we do have
other options so for example we do have
a drone capacity that's been reviewed so
things like hair coursing we can use
drones and we are looking at the badger
set um disturbances looking at cameras
that are completely different to cctv
cameras but other digital solutions for
some of those crime types
so i'll say it counselor carter
and i've now got
councilloreck pinyon
councillor hinson you had your hand up
and councillor wellam in that order
thank you
thank you madam chairman um
i did actually appreciate the response i
got from commander janine to my crime
rate question
um
but then i note the comment from
vicki mosley about the tendency of the
crime rate so
traditional crimes are going down other
crimes are going up particularly she
said online fraud which is brings me to
my question because
there is no mention
in this report at all relating to online
fraud or any
similar types of scams that are
reflecting particularly our older
members of our population and i note
that this is an issue that's come to the
fore quite a lot with the closure of
banks
particularly which seems to be the main
area of these scams and frauds and i
wonder
what our plan is to tackle that in our
particular region
um
and and um
if you could perhaps address that
question for me that'd be great
yep thank you you're absolutely right so
this the outcomes of the strategic
assessment is the highlighting that ford
is an activity that we need to be
mindful of um without having the actual
figures in front of me i did ask the
question about you know which
what cohort of our communities were most
at risk and in actual fact the figures
are showing that it isn't actually our
older cohort it is the age ranges of the
mid
30s to 40s that seem to be more at risk
of fraudulent activities perhaps
they just might be buying more stuff we
don't know the detail of that yet and
that's what we're expecting to come out
of the strategic assessment once we've
had feedback on all of that then we will
absolutely be including fraud as one of
the priorities once we've discussed it
as a pr as a csp partnership within the
the action plan going forward so that's
where we will then start to tackle what
does that look like how can we affect it
as
a local authority what the police do
what our other partners can do but we
need to drill down a little bit more
into that detail and like i say that's
hopefully what will come out of the
strategic assessment which is coming to
his conclusion um this month
uh right well that that's great um
i think actually you sort of answered
part of my question and po and given me
another question because i think
actually um because it's something i
look into a lot
um
that your comment about the the age if
you like the 30
to 40 group being more prone to fraud
because they do more online
transactions is true but
also it is true in fact that the older
population are more prone to
banking scams on financial scams and the
the financial and economic impact of
that is much more severe i would suggest
than than what's going on uh in the
online transaction i'm not saying that
they're not important and i'm i i have a
concern that you know people's
ability to
economically look after themselves of
being
undermined and i just wonder whether the
the police in particular actually have
the tools and the wherewithal to be able
to actually tackle these kinds of crimes
so cyber crime is a challenge because um
it's not normally happening in suffolk
it could happen all over so the city of
london police lead on ford and
cybercrime for the whole of uk they're
the mpcc leads suffolk has set up a new
cyber crime unit i'd honest i'm not
going to ask any questions because i
only know because my my one of my
detective inspectors has gone to lead on
it so it is being looked at a lot more
closely and the best things we can do at
the moment because it is hard it's it's
a very um complex
you know strategies that people use them
is our community engagement officers
it's one of the things they do focus on
when they do their drop-ins and coffee
groups and that there's a lot of scam
leaflets there's a lot of and it is
we do the most we can around educating
one thing i would say is though that is
the banks do a lot of this themselves
now and
the actual guidance that a bank would
give out about what to do we do need to
encourage people to follow that because
that's your best protection is following
the guidance that bank gives you about
we won't phone you and actually this we
won't phone you and ask you that so they
do quite a lot themselves as a private
industry
madam chairman we'll leave it at that
okay thank you
thank you chair um
just a quick one on the cctv
uh we seem to spend an awful lot of
money on it and uh
as i've mentioned earlier the east of
the district doesn't seem to get a lot
of anything it seems to be forgotten
about most of the time on all sorts of
things but looking at the report on page
49 paragraph 8.55 it talks about 96
incidents have been recorded leading to
43 arrests
my question is one what sort of
incidents are they
reporting
two
what is the outcome of these arrests how
many people have been prosecuted and
three were they in sudbury hadley or
where because for
36 cameras
and a mobile one we'll be getting a
little bit more than that surely
yeah when we we will be able to provide
more information on those and i'd be
happy to share that but in terms of the
incidents that we're picking up that's
all sorts of incidents whether that be
violent crimes theft it's whatever gets
spotted so it's they're the kinds of
types of crimes that are being reported
um in terms of what happens after the
arrest i can i don't know the answer to
that question that's something i'll have
to have a conversation with janine with
afterwards and come back to you but we
do and we are beginning to receive
performance reports which we can share
so i'm happy to do so after this meeting
council if that would um
if you would like to see sight of those
councillor davis you want to yeah um
just very briefly
in terms of the sighting of the cctv
this is very much police led because
the police will say
where they need
cameras in sudbury and hadley for the
rest of the district obvious it's very
difficult to be able to say well let's
put a cctv here because it has to be
cost effective and i take your point
about how many crimes are solved and
the benefit of it and there's also the
public perception uh for safety and
security as well
so yeah
um it would lead as vicky said earlier
about um a threshold of saying well you
know where do we need these cameras and
why do we need them and
you know who's going to pay for them
because although baber
paid for
um a huge chunk of the money for the
cctv it was the town councils from both
areas that contributed greatly to that
as well and uh and and just to add to
that i thank um councillor osborne for
his um kind words but it was a whole
communities team dave clark in
particular did an excellent job in
coordinating that
with the town council and with the
police and just further
it's anecdotes a little bit but i
happened to be at the town council
meeting or watching the town council
meeting when mike small the uh safer
neighborhood officer for hadley made his
report and he made mention of uh how
beneficial the cctv was again in hadley
um
and also
uh he gave a very comprehensive
breakdown of the crime figures for the
previous three months there as well
perhaps that's something that we can
look at
getting extended onto the peninsula and
into his burglar because he did bring
cable into it which he'd been covering
as well
come on come back
yeah uh thank you very much indeed yes i
would like the the information please
um
on the point of what uh is reported from
uh hadley town council and to hadley
town council i'm not sure that uh my
parishes will be that interested in what
goes on in hadley probably more
interesting what went on in manning tree
because that's where they tend to tend
to spend an awful lot of their time but
of course that's a different county but
they are contributing to both paper by
their council tax to
the police by the this
precept
and they obviously like to see something
for it not just to support the rest of
the district it's something that's going
to benefit them as well
okay counselor
thank you chair um
yeah sorry i've got a few more questions
um
most of them are to do with pages 54 and
so on 53 54 55 and the first is on at
the top of page 54
a project reference 8
which is to do with
proactive promotion and communication
and we have a list there of
national campaigns which seems to stop
at november 2020.
is that a glitch of the i.t
um i presume there have been national
campaigns since then um so um
and and the districts have had their own
campaigns or they've they have
um piggybacked on the national campaign
i guess
uh and that has a that are they then
funded by the district um and presumably
there is an impact on staffing if
if there is a national campaign on
let's say
well we talk about white ribbon um
national there's a national hate crime
awareness week so
presumably there's some
um
uh some communication some promotion
centrally and then we
we piggyback during the same week
presumably
yeah so the report you've got in front
of you in terms of action plan is um up
to the end of quarter three so that
would have been updated ready for
quarter four so you don't have that
report because at the time of publishing
we hadn't completed quarters four so we
would have added on to that
most recent campaigns as well so for
example two weeks ago there was the um
week of prevent so and largely we work
alongside our colleagues at suffolk
county council who produce a
standardized set of kind of campaign um
information which is then shared with
all csp areas and then we then
distribute whether that's within our own
councils or within a health
setting or an educational setting um so
um
and so yes we're picking back so in
terms of a lot of the campaigns we
schedule those particularly if they are
so from a district council's point of
view if they're a csv priority we
schedule those into our annual service
delivery plan so it becomes core
business as usual and we tend to use the
resources and the tools that are created
centrally but yes we piggyback on a lot
of that but we we tend to try and
resource for those campaigns within our
kind of core activities if you like
but on page 54 it looks as if from the
national point of view it's
it's historic it
it ends at november 2020 unless that is
a glitch of the i.t
i think it must be yep sorry so so
basically i think that just might be a a
yeah a typo and a glitch so um so you
have got a list of what the next
campaigns will be it's not just a
historic list you've got a
a list of campaigns that you will be
feeding into in the future not just
what's happened two years ago yeah no we
have an annual list of campaigns and
they are all aligned to the the cs
priorities the police have additional
campaigns that they will lead on and we
might have other campaigns that we lead
on as well and what we try to do is
within that list of um campaigns
and working again with colleagues across
the county we don't just deliver the
campaigns we then do a piece of
retrospective work to look at the the
the reach of those campaigns the impact
it might have had so we then we can
report those back as well but yes we
have an annual program
thank you now i'm now still on the same
page
um
we've we've got uh in in the table we've
got
as a heading the lead and we've got
names
and then in the next pack the next
column
we have
start date sequence and in almost every
case
we read that the lead is to set the
start date which suggests to me
that
these things haven't started
and we're relying on a quite a small
number of people
to
kick off
all of these projects
um
are just a little bit concerned that if
we haven't started these projects and
we're relying on probably about five
people
across the piece
five named people
is it is it fair on them that they've
got to start all this lot off
or
i think in terms of where it says the
the start date and sequence you're
absolutely right i'm looking at that now
that hasn't been picked up by the
partnership all of those things have
been started but apart from the one
project that was identified earlier on
around prevent and safe spaces so they
they tend to be ongoing activities so
there will be different start dates for
different types of activities so we need
to to address that as a partnership and
we can pick that up on wednesday when we
meet next
um
there are a number of named officers in
there but they are the
the local authority leads who will then
bring back some of those activities to
the local authorities so it isn't just
those officers that are responsible for
delivering those particular programs but
the wider teams that sit around those
individuals so i would so it's not a set
group of five officers it's them and um
so for example myself and frankenstein
on behalf of baby mr district council
but i will make use of the whole of my
community's team to deliver some of the
activity so it's not just those officers
responsible
um my last question you'll be pleased to
hear
there's a reference to sudbury cctv no
reference to cctv in mid-suffolk
um presumably everything's working well
i've got no reasons to believe that cctv
is something isn't working well nothing
has come on to onto the radar um we have
picked up the fact that we do have sort
of discrepancies in the level of
reporting that we we're getting back and
we'd love to going to be looking to do
something about that as we proceed we've
waited really to get the um the baby
cctv camera work out of the way so we
can then focus to see what benefits and
what what conclusions we can um achieve
from what's happening in mid-support but
that's on our radar it's not happening
so the partnership would have a review
of the cctv provision not the
partnership the reason it's included in
here was because we were showing the the
level of proactivity around um asb and
the work that we were doing in sudbury
so um as part of baber and we were
contributing and showing the work that
we've been we've been doing so when we
do similar work uh in mid-south because
that's when we will add that in terms of
the activity update but it was more as
an update rather than an action for the
csp yeah okay thank you
thank you councillor
and what i'm going to do is i've got two
questions
of my own and then i uh that will bring
the questions to an end but uh i'd like
to ask two questions
um
on page three we talk about
criminal
exploitation
engaging with communities that's quite a
broad word
which communities are you referring to
and how do you engage with them
so in in my earlier statement i talked
about some of the work that we hadn't
been able to achieve through the fact
that we've been limited in terms of how
much engagement we've been able to
actively go out so a lot of the work
around criminal exploitation has been
around awareness raising delivering
rapid training which is workshops raise
awareness of uh prevent which also links
into criminal exploitation as well so
it's been around sort of that
professional
awareness raising um more than anything
else at the moment but with restrictions
now um almost disappearing then our
program activity next for next year will
be about how we work with community
groups like like the mix for example
and then just
taking some of that training that we
have ourselves as officers and as
members and taking that into uh some of
our community groups whether that's
supporting parish councils or some of
those community groups that typically
work with younger people so that's
that's what we'll be doing for next year
thank you and my second question is
about modern slavery
my understanding from discussions with
councillor wellum that we already have
some missing children
in suffolk i think the police and crime
commissioner has raised this
given the the current situation in
ukraine and where there are over a
hundred thousand missing children in
ukraine
what um this is for jeanine really what
preparation are we making it to try and
prevent some of these missing children
being
recruited
by these um
you know
people who
want to exploit as many people as
possible
society do you mean children coming from
ukraine or current well we already have
a problem with some missing children i
think or i'd have to know what pcc's
past more was referring to there because
i'm not aware of
there were some missing children aren't
they
yeah chair if if i may help um i'm a
member of the police and crime panel and
one of the concerns of the police
and crime commissioner is
that there are children who go missing
from
um establishments
um
and
there's there doesn't seem
to be
a sort of like a a joined up way of a
finding them
and or b
making sure that they don't escape again
and i think what what um
uh the chief constable is concerned
about
it often falls back on the police
because nobody else is picking it up
sort of support from council
so these children which is of concern to
all of us i think and then the possible
influx of of other children
because at least well the last numbers i
heard was a hundred thousand children
are not accounted for in the
um the great exodus from ukraine what
are we what would we be doing
as a county or the police would be doing
as a as the
official body in trying to prevent
the um
the people that procure the services
under modern slavery of children
so i'll start with what we're doing now
because i would imagine that's what
we'll do when if we do get into ukraine
but i can't specifically answer that
we've not got the plans in place for
that so under precept in the last few
years
suffolk conservatory has had an uplift
of six offices in total but it's three
missing person advisors and three modern
slavery advisors
and they work very closely together and
what they do is when we have children go
missing we don't just
i mean the traditional way didn't the
person is quite robust actually the
powers we have to locate them using
phones et cetera et cetera is very
robust but what they do is a very
comprehensive follow-up now
and and they will do return interviews
we'll look at their
wider situation we'll refer them again
into the mesh if we need to we also um
have across suffolk now the mace panels
which are set up which is the
multi-agency
criminal exploitation
um multi-agency groups so actually one
of those children returns and actually
think hang on a minute they've returned
with a lot of money a new phone we think
there could be something happen while
they're away the research
referred into that panel where together
with education health and we all come
together they're risk assessed and a
plan will be put in place to tackle the
exploitation and to support them out of
it so actually there's some actually
really good things in place now to
address not only the missing expert but
the things that could happen while child
is missing
thank you
um
committee i think we have um is there
anybody else that's got a burning
question
i think we're all questioned there
actually uh councillor david
yeah there was just something that i
thought was worth mentioning to
the chance is partly one of your
questions in one of councillor carter's
questions um as part of the partnership
and the wider working that we have
within the communities teams and we have
things called domestic abuse champions
and these are council
officers that are specifically trained
up to
recognize certain situations and how to
deal with them and that's part of the
the neighborhood
your neighbors or the community wanting
to report and they may not want to
report directly to the police
especially maybe in early incidents but
they can use other avenues to report
domestic abuse which goes back to your
community engagement and a little bit
about the awareness
um you know to help people who may be
sit in situations of abuse converse of
control etc i just thought it was worth
mentioning that is part of the
the training that the partnership has
has helped introduce
thank you councillor davis
so we've come to the stage
of debate and at this point i'd like to
thank
janine and vicky councillor davis and
councillor mansell
if you wish to leave
and i know
janine you've got other duties that are
calling you so we're very happy for you
but we want to say thank you very much
for the presentation and the report and
thank you for answering our questions
thank you very much
so the committee has got to decide do
you want to debate
before a gap in the proceedings
or
would you like a 10-minute break and we
come back and debate the issue i'm sure
everybody is ready to go
so can we have a hop
sorry
so i'm just announcing official great
great sorry for the record of 10 minutes
and
come back at just before half past 11.
thank you very much
thank you so welcome back committee i
hope you feel suitably refreshed
we're now into a period of debate
um following the presentation
uh who would like to
start the debate
councillor custom
yeah i think the debate should be um
what recommendations
we're making i'm happy to um propose
that we um
do
do you want me to propose that this
committee notes the report
um
i think it's a um i think it's a really
good report it's really i think we've um
we've proved that this
partnership um adds value to
the
safety um the community safety
of baber and mid-suffolk
um
i think i think it's well produced
and it's very informative and they're
doing a lot of
good work um
i did wonder if are we um
recommending to the partnership
i should think we are um
it just strikes me that the um the name
the western
suffolk safety partnership is a bit out
of date it's sort of a leftover from
previous councils and it's
it's not much of a
recommendation but i think they should
really um
think about changing that because um
from a um
the public's perception
i just don't think um
people will realize that it applies to
you know baber mid suffolk and um
and isn't for west suffolk um
[Music]
yeah but i'm i'm happy to take on any
other recommendations with that proposal
for this
yes i'd like to um propose that we um we
note this report have i got a sector
thank you councillor osborne but i'd
like to uh come be just before we go on
to any more recommendations are there
any comments that the committee would
like to make in debate
yeah councillor
chair despite the questions that
councillor hinton asked and the answers
that were given i'm still not clear
whether the shotley peninsula is in the
east
or the west
it is in the western area right because
at one point we were told that the
statistics will be with the felix those
statistics so
um yes so um anyway when we come on to
um further recommendations i i will say
something to that end
lahensen do you want to uh yeah i think
that was one thing that was actually
cleared up that it is that the
area east of hadley is actually part of
this partnership
um
the name causes more confusion so i
agree with the the name of to be
reconsidered
um
but also
some of the content of the report is
statistic statistically based
but
the statistics that they're working on
are nationally gathered and then
extrapolated which means that they're
always going to be a little bit confused
and i must admit i was always told that
statistic statistics and damn lies or
was it lies lies and damn statistics
whichever way around in other words you
don't trust them because you can prove
anything with them if you want to i'm
not saying that's the case here but it
does rather confuse the issue
when
figures are extrapolated and then used
to to formulate policies and
actions
so i think that's something that should
be looked at a bit more carefully and if
it was a little bit
tighter in terms of the boundaries and
the name
they could help
yeah
the name is a really difficult one but
the um
it is the western suffolk community
safety partnership not west suffolk um
but yeah i can see how that how that
causes confusion but
the question would be what would you
replace the name with
because there's no easy geographical
name
that comes to my mind that you could
actually replace it with to reflect the
fact that it covers west suburba and
mid-supper apart from if you had an
extremely unwieldy title of west suffolk
mid-south baby suffolk you know et
cetera
um
so
be careful what you wish for because you
might end up with something that's
actually
more difficult to comprehend uh and and
turns into an acronym which nobody knows
what it's about
um
well we have and there are a lot in this
paper as well which is exactly the point
um
i was interested in the um
the traffic light scheme because i think
it did show
there were two or three areas where
there's a red flag and there needs to be
some significant progress on
um we did get an update
from um vicky that sort of said well
there is more information to hand
and i think um
obviously we haven't got quite the
latest uh information
to hand when we're discussing this and
that would have been useful because she
did elaborate on further work that was
under being undertaken on the prevent
strategy so i just wondered about
whether members um from well not just
this committee but members baber and mid
suffolk it would be a good idea to uh
publish a link to this report and then
when we get that quarter
report
up update particularly the members of
this committee but i think all members
would be interested because there's
clearly
on the two councils a little bit of a
misunderstanding about what it's all
about so the more information we can
spread i think would be useful because
it does highlight
the agencies that you need to contact as
a councillor etc and the ways into the
system so i think spreading the
information would be one of the
recommendations
i i would like to see and also the
timing of it if if we are
just after another quarters reporting
but we haven't actually got the physical
report in front of us then perhaps we
should consider
whether we move that annual review to
immediately after the publication of a
quarter
just just a few questions there
i actually think there was too much
information in that
sort of concertina bit of paper that
people could not really it needs to be
presented in a simpler form i think
kathy can i kind of just in relation to
that kathy the strategic assessment
are we is that going to be a public
document
i would have to confirm that
i i'm not sure
it's been mentioned i mean it was
mentioned the other day um but it was
mentioned today and
it doesn't mean anything to
members that are just listening to that
information
where you know where is it coming from
and who's going to produce it and how
often is it going to be produced
because that that
recognizing that a lot of the assessment
of the services
was going to be in that report
so i can confirm that the that there is
a strategic assessment updated annually
right um i will come back to you in
terms of whether that is a holy public
document and but certainly we'd be able
to come back with information on the key
areas um
in that strategic assessment when that's
been completed
thank you
thank you madam chairman um just
following up on councillor scarce point
um regarding the um
the review in on pages 53 to 55 they did
that uh
action plan with the red green and amber
i think
um
[Music]
less would be more
to be pretty bluntly um we have i think
five columns there
detailing quarterly activities and and
if you read through it in detail you'll
see there's a lot of repetition
and i believe actually we could just do
with one column on activity within that
really up to date status on that and
that would make the report much more
concise and
more digestible if i may suggest
counsellor barrett
thank you um
that's you know that's that this is the
crux of it this this report i suppose um
and it would be interesting to know who
is the author who is whose document is
this
is it
baber's document do we own it and so do
we have responsibility for for it
because that column date
start date
what's it say uh sequence
where it
many of them say lead to set start date
that isn't
updated it's difficult to know well
where'd you go back to to to sort of um
prod
or
request
that that to be maintained
and it if that is not constantly being
updated referred to reviewed then surely
the
the actions
aren't flowing out very very well
um and i guess the point about the
just showing the most recent that's
quite achievable isn't it because if the
if these columns were in the right order
they could the the screen could be
frozen at one stage and you would just
hide the other
um
updates
as you go into each new quarter
so that would it would slide underneath
the others don't if you're you're
familiar with spreadsheets but that
that's possible as long as they're in
the right order
um
so is
that that ownership i'm not quite clear
about
if i could just confirm that the action
plan is owned by the partnership board
um as a whole um
and um i can see myself that there are
some things that that need to be updated
um and and will be for the next
partnership
for the next partnership board i realize
that there's a lag time in terms of
those updates and when this this report
is published
counselor
could i just ask kathy when this is
updated in
a few weeks time
presumably that it will be updated as an
annual report because it will be
quarter four
and
so
members of the partnership will be able
to see what action has been taken over
the four quarters of the year
and i just wondered whether
when it is updated
that's something which all members ought
to be aware of and then presumably at
some point
there will there will be a new
a new action plan
or a modified action plan
i i guess that yeah having got to the
end of this year
as a new action plan
um
yeah because it is 21 to 22. um
i think i think members need to be a bit
more all members not members of this
committee all members need to be a bit
more aware
of
what the partnership does
and i just wondered whether
um
besides
giving some feedback to the partnership
itself
whether we ought to
recommend to officers
that there is some some information
given to
uh all members including
the action plan with a simpler format um
and it may be just an annual update
maybe the simple format that we we give
to to members
um
uh with and include maps so that so that
people are absolutely clear
whether well that what what what area is
covered
and i think what would be useful would
be some updated tips on what to look for
and how to report
we did have some information probably
about three years ago
and i think we had a briefing also to
all members
but it would have been pre-covered and
significantly pre-covered
um
so and i think we were given a little
card
the number to the number to ring
and when you should ring and when you
shouldn't ring and what you can expect
to happen
so i think that would be useful
can i come
so that would be my recommendation can i
come back on the statistics piece
because
it's a real shame that the pcc didn't
send a representative here i did ask for
that i know the officers asked
and i'd hoped that vanessa would come
because she has got um she's she's one
of the like assistants
one of one of tim's
senior people
and she she has access to lots of local
statistics so
i'm sure the partnership
doesn't all doesn't only look
at
national statistics uh
in terms of
promotions and communications and and so
on i guess they look to the national
statistics but and but for most of the
time they must look at the local
statistics
um the other thing is i think at some
point
there needs to be an update on their
projects they've
still read but i
i don't i don't think we want to report
back here in about three months time
so they can tell us what they've done in
the meantime i i think we should make
our points
to
two officers and then leave the
partnership to sort it out we've got we
do this annually we don't want to start
doing it more frequently than that
thank you
oh thank you um one of the second term
council epcon's point about
having more concise data
i would actually say
possibly rather than having it on one
single chart
it'd be beneficial to have it in two or
three charts one for
previous activities always good to be
aware of what's happened even if it's a
repeat of what we're doing
current and one for future
if i had it in just three separate
charts when we can see it and know what
action points are to be aware of
and the future column can actually say
the variety of
color coordinated
i would also say that um second um
council of women's points about be
leading the geographical for maps it
would be very beneficial to certainly be
beneficial to myself
um just be to see the areas cupboards
um
uh
ask for a name you could just call it
the partnership
that's one way of doing it
um
and
i'll move on to my final point i just
completely flown with the coop so
i'll come back to it
councillor custom
thank you um
yeah i just wanted to um
go over these recommendations a little
bit the um
i think that um
um
i think the name thing we've got to be
careful that we don't overstep the mark
i think the recommendation should be
purely we don't believe
that the name
is helpful for people to understand the
geographic area because um
western suffolk is definitely not
shortly peninsula
um
so i think i don't i don't think we
should suggest a name or anything we
should just bring that to
the partnership's attention
um
councillor welland was saying about
extra training for councillors i think
um
do you mean the um the safeguarding
training that we do every three years is
that is that what you're
talking about cheers i think it's a bit
like that but although that's that's
fairly formal training i think what we
what we need is probably
a a briefing on an updated briefing and
uh
perhaps a little pack that like we had
before which is
what to look for
and how to report
um because the world has changed as you
as cancer casting said the world has
changed and what we need to be looking
out for
now
is probably quite different to to what
we need to be looking at what we needed
to be looking out for
but the safeguarding training um i mean
that gives all the legal background and
everything else i don't i don't think we
need any uh interim training on all of
that
um
keith are you
are you talking about members of the
committee or all members of all members
should have safeguarding training no no
i understand but this is a bit different
you're looking there are a lot of
aspects more than safeguarding in this
um now i think
i i think
ev every member of the two the two
district councils ought to in my view
have a bit of an update
on what the key issues are
and and what to look out for
in a um
so
um you've got the the priorities which
are in in that's on page three
that gives you areas that you could
do you see the headings there
are you suggesting an update on those
headings
no i think something probably more
more simple than that
not you know if if
if you see some uh some suspicious
behavior and it's uh
take it take a note of it and and you
know what should you look out for if you
think it is suspicious and what
information should you give i mean like
looking at my
window at home i saw this same black car
come along
uh three days running and a young lad
with a with a you know a black hoodie
and a black duffel bag run down run down
an alleyway and run back again and the
car went round in a circle
picked him up again
10 or 15 minutes later
for people to to look out for things
like that
i mean that's the that's a fairly
obvious example i guess
but that's
wouldn't
sort of a handout for members rather
than members coming into a briefing
would a out
addressing all those
but i think i think let's just go with
council yeah i think i think there needs
to be a handout i mean one of the
one of the debates that we had us a
while ago in overview of scrutiny was
that
do all members look at handout uh you
need you need to you almost tell them
what's in the handout then give them the
handout and then ask them if they've
asked some questions about it
i think this this is sufficiently
important that that would
could it could be just an hour online of
training but i think
i think i think members need
to be made aware that this is a real
issue and that they have got a role
okay we're just going to ask uh emily
before i come to councillor carter emily
thank you chair and good morning
committee um i think that you might be
alluding to a toolkit that we produced
previously councillor welum which i
think was as a result of this exact
debate a few years ago so i think one of
the actions that we could take away is
to update that toolkit
if council has found that useful in the
past and that was sort of a guide for
all members about how you should report
things key phone numbers um key contacts
that kind of thing um but i do think
there's potentially a
um
an idea here for a member training
session
around your role as ward members
and community leaders about keeping your
community safe and what your role is in
terms of reporting and how you should do
that and the types of things that you
might look out for and also how you um
enable your parish and town councils to
have those sensible conversations about
incidents that are having
that are taking place in their areas so
you know we we know that we have pockets
of antisocial behavior we know that we
have concerns about county lines
and just equipping you with the
knowledge and the awareness of the right
routes to report those things so you can
have those kind of um more detailed
conversations in in your parishes as
well so i think that's something that we
could look at chair if the committee
would like that
i think i think we're looking at the the
toolkit sounds a good idea
and and probably supported by a briefing
but i think you'd need two things
together actually
i think i think the briefings are
excellent but um
we're attending a lot of briefings and
it's just another letter of information
um sorry melanie
councillor carter you had your hand up
thank you yes actually brought me back
to what the final point would have been
if i hadn't flown in kubernetes
the mention of a toolkit is great
but what we really need we have a
members area on when we look like log
onto the computer computer
it would be ideal to have a tab a
members tab that we can keep up to date
the toolkit
will be relevant and then expire if we
had an up-to-date one on the website and
not only just for members not only just
for
counselors
it'd be beneficial for
our residents as a whole as well if we
had something on our website
as well about reporting what they can do
who to reach out to
not that they can reach out to
us as community leaders as councillors
but also when reporting to
crimes to different things what numbers
they can use
this is a resource that would be
beneficial to everyone not just
counsellors
so that's something worth looking into
catholic can that be pursued
absolutely on the website
absolutely yeah yeah i think i think for
parent and i think we're in a position
where we should be influencing parish
and town councils as well
and we need that information um
sorry go to james next council caster
um directed
in the right place i'm a bit worried
about getting mission creep where
officers
um
do work that
can be found somewhere else and we got
to be very
careful as this committee
that we don't um we're talking about
work within the council now but we don't
create work for the um the western
suffolk
safety partnership when they should be
doing their job which they they do
really well so um
i am
i think if if there's a way of doing
this that we're not
re-doing work that we can find somewhere
else i think that's probably the best
way of doing it yeah i think the review
of the toolkit
is a really good idea that's
you know that that's really important
um we did um we talked about appendix
one which is um quite complicated um but
the information is there so we've got to
be really careful that we don't ask for
more and more from a um an organization
that needs to be doing
other things like more you know
more important work when we've got the
information there but yeah i totally
agree with what's been said and i'm
happy to um
i'd recommend dations okay just before
we go there councillor barrett
thank you um
some of the thoughts just heard
um
i think if if i had concerns about
criminal activities that i wasn't sure
about i think i'd go onto the police's
website rather than the local council so
although i you know it might be useful
to have a page on our website
sign posting people to the the correct
places i think really we we want to make
sure that the information is out there
on the places where people are likely to
look first in the first place if that is
missing then we should be influencing
that that body um
to to ensure that they is covered in the
and that
and it's got to be in a place where it's
going to get updated by the people who
know what they're talking about very
quickly because things can get out of
date very quickly
so if it's on the police website then i
think that is the best place for that
information to be so they can report
through
um also on the training for counsellors
we have a lot of training and we don't
get very good attendance always
especially when if it comes back to face
to face as well we'll probably see that
possibly affected by the need to travel
so i think it should be that training
should be within our safeguarding
training
because that is a mandate mandatory
attendance
um and it could be included a lot of it
crosses over anyway
um to to to make sure our residents and
really we are only 70 orders
so
we as long as yes we can be trained but
we're not out there
in vast numbers
it's really important that the wider
community understands
the types of behavior that is considered
you know exploitative or or
the um
damaging to to to residents so
i think
that's what i would suggest
thank you chair i i was just going to
comment on what council carter said
about um having information which is
available to the public um the
information that we were given
um last time around had confidential
numbers confidential telephone numbers
on so if there is something for the
public would probably have to be
different
um
and uh
well councillor barrett's raised a very
good point that yeah we've only got one
pair of eyes and there are hundreds of
other pairs of eyes out there but my
experience
living in a village is
if an individual has one of the
residents has seen something that looks
a bit suspicious they've usually come to
ask me if it really is suspicious so i
think we do need to know a little bit
more than the general public and and you
know we we are we are out there we we go
to
we go to
all sorts of places within our our patch
where we can have a discussion
i i i remember having a discussion the
retail outlet
because um
a young lad had gone in there
to buy something and when he'd opened
his wallet it was stuff full of 20-pound
notes
now
that's a little bit suspicious you know
a scruffy individual i'm not saying
there's anything wrong with it i didn't
know whether there was anything wrong
with it but i think that's the sort of
that's the sort of thing that we need
somebody needs some guidance on um and
in that case i had a discussion with her
with the retailer um
and uh yeah it did it did turn out that
it was somebody who was under suspicion
i think we've got to be very careful
though about making assumptions about
people well we we do have yeah we
mustn't make assumptions but we if if we
if we raise if there is an alarm bell
raised by a resident we need to know
what to do with that
right we're back to the recommendations
so can we have some
councillor now
thank you um well i i i understand where
councilman welling's coming from and i i
definitely sympathize with council
barrett's points
but i would have to say that in my
experience um if there is an issue
uh and for example in stone market we've
had some issues with county lines i can
assure members and officers that people
do ring me up and say well you know
what's being done about this and and i
make this a suitable follow-up i mean
obviously leave it to
the the organizations and officers
with the the expertise and
responsibility to to basically look into
it and hopefully come to a resolution
although sometimes these things do take
quite a while to become resolved um so i
do think we have a
duty of care
uh to understand how we deal with these
situations even if it is
just being the messenger and acting as
an
interlocutor between you know the
agencies that are dealing with the
problem and the people who raise the
problem are experiencing the problem so
there is there is that i think the one
thing i would say about this report is
that it is extensive
i wouldn't like to say whether it's
entirely comprehensive or not because in
my view
uh given the points i made earlier i
don't think it is comprehensive enough
but i don't particularly like the
structure of it i think it's too bitty
um and and we ought to be looking at
these
in the silos to which it as it has
defined itself in terms of priorities
um and also i do believe that a lot of
the
data that's being presented could be
better presented and i think there's
better analysis that could be done that
would make it much easier for for
councillors reading this report to
actually understand
where the real pinpoints are and where
the thrust of activity ought to be and i
don't see that from this report so i
would encourage
some work to be done on that front yeah
thank you i think um you will have
noticed that the difference between last
year and this year was that we
councillor wellam and i agreed that we
wanted less people presenting
because of the years there's been many
people
giving their viewpoint and that gets
confusing so
we tried to condense the report this
time but uh councillor castin
we can start off with we need some more
recommends so start with your
recommendation please
well
i think um
if we're going to put it um quite simply
i think um
i think i'm account councillor ekpanyong
just
did it very
very well the the report in future
could be
simplified
and
um i can't remember the exact words you
used but um
more yeah more concise
um
yeah i think um
the other
recommendation i've heard is the review
of the toolkit that the council uses
and
a read a redistribution
sorry
chair sorry to interrupt um i've been uh
typing some suggested recommendations as
you've been speaking so i'll read them
out if that's okay i've got five from
the um discussion that you've had so
firstly that the comments made by the
committee regarding the name of the
partnership and the format of the action
plan be reported back to the
crime partnership
that the reporting toolkit for all
members be updated and circulated
that a training session be held for all
members to ensure that all councillors
have knowledge and awareness of their
role in respective repo of identifying
and reporting crime and safety issues in
their area and are able to support their
town and parish councils when discussing
crime and safety
that a simplified version of the action
plan is circulated to all councillors
with the ons chairs report to full
council on this item
and to review the timing of the wsc sp
report based on the meeting cycle of the
partnership and ensuring that the most
up-to-date position is reported
to strategic assessment actually
i'd like
at the strategic assessment cafe yeah i
know you're going to pursue it but i
think it's worth us just asking the
question
whether we have access to the strategic
assessment issued by the county council
um is everybody happy with
i think we're having
those recommendations
and we're noting that of course we're
noting the report anyway aren't we yeah
we have to do that do we councillor
osborne yes seconding to uh
james i i must absolutely agree with
that and what emily has
produced i think and of course all epic
young
regarding the nature of the report
jeff i may i was thinking that actually
as i read out number five that i hadn't
captured the
um
rationalization of the poor report shall
we say and and more of a strategic focus
in instead of the level of detail that
we've had so if we incorporate that into
um
recommendation five to say that we'll
not only review the timing but also um
condense the the information provided in
the report
does that work
sort of works i thought condensed wasn't
wouldn't be the word i had in mind but i
mean you need a more concise
report with with better analysis of the
data
the presentation of the information was
confusing
actually
who's taking that are you taking it down
anyway
okay
counselor
counselor carter
with regards to the updates and
redistribution distribution with the
councillors
um i did wonder if we could keep
updating keep that live rather than just
a one-off regards to be numbers and that
lots
whether regardless if it's
on a tab or just an email update if any
changes in the future occur to ever
process
the update sheet the update card could
that be a live one rather than just one
this year and then on the following
meetings where it's requested again
could it just be
kept fluid as it is
you know in a way isn't that a lot of
work for somebody
in the in the plethora of information
has to go out from the council from
offices
is that an omnis task are we asking too
much
i think inevitably the information is
going to change you know
probably one year to the next so i mean
i would suggest that um if we were going
to issue a if we were going to issue
some sort of physical card that we there
would need to be an online version for
you where you got um updates
you know at least a couple of times a
year
right
although obviously the digital version
will be will be much more um
up to yeah that would be much more up to
date that's the problem with cards is
they get out of date very quickly but i
understand also how useful they can be
but it that the problem with all the
stuff that we do as members is it
depends what our interest in is as a
member
and so it could be a very limited
group of people that are looking for
that update
council
um i yeah i completely understand what
council carter's saying there and um i
think that would be useful but
with the amount of value that this
committee brings to the partnership i
don't think it's worth doing
personally
i think um until if if this committee
had brought a huge amount of value to
the partnership or
you know i think that would be um
that would be important but we do have
offices on that partnership dealing with
this and we do look at this once a year
which i think is completely appropriate
to um what it is um
and
and how much value we can add to it um
so
i'm not too keen on
on that recommendation i think we're
doing this the right amount of time once
a year and
with officers in place on that
partnership and um and members as well
you know very
you know in very important positions i
think i think we're dealing with that
exactly like we should
yeah thank you madam cheerio i
absolutely agree with the counselor
casting i think that's the right way to
go and
i was going to ask
read it out again so that all the
committee are quite clear what we're
recommending is that okay
thank you
thank you chair so in terms of that
recommendation five um
and so after the um
review of the timing of the report so
still being an annual report but making
it
fit better into the pattern of meetings
that the partnership actually undertakes
we would add to review the format of the
report to ensure that the information is
clear concise and has a strategic focus
with regards to the uh publication of a
toolkit and actually any guidance that
we produce
for councillors it is placed on the
information library in your members area
so whenever we produce something we also
would put a digital copy in that
members area for you obviously there is
a task we're trying to keep all of that
information up to date and inevitably
some of it will go out of date at any
point in time
but we're always happy if a counsellor
notices that something has fallen out of
date just let committee services know
and we'll arrange with the relevant
officers to get that that updated so if
we haven't periodically updated
something then we can do that on
requests so we would put the toolkit
into that members library as well
recommendations um
henrietta said we've got all of those
down
yes chad i have and i've just got logged
out
on the training are we saying a bespoke
training particularly about this in
addition to the
uh
would you like me to read that
recommendation again
i think that the training session is to
be held for all members to ensure all
council have knowledge and awareness of
the role and respect of identifying and
reporting crime and safety issues in the
area and are able to support their their
town and parish councils when discussing
crime and safety so
yes
yes
um i think in terms of the delivery of
that session we'd look at whether that
was best tied in with a safeguarding
session for example or perhaps tied in
with a wider briefing around um you know
pcc briefing something like that so we'd
look at making it a really valuable
session and obviously advertising that
to members and we'd also look at the
format it doesn't necessarily need to be
a briefing style it could be e-learning
you know we're always looking at
different mechanisms to
impart knowledge so we would work with
the
member development working group take
their thoughts and then create that
training package around that need
which this is this training and there's
another training that's about safety of
residents and and and there's a little
bit of uh a blurring of lines so perhaps
a bit in it it probably would be useful
to attach it to the police and crime
commissioner review i reckon
yeah good idea
governance officer will conduct the
electronic vote and i can't get into
mine
and it's state that is to vote on the
recommendations as read by the committee
clerk
council mclaren may i take your vote
verbally
chair that is nine votes four that's
unanimous
thank you
appreciate your tolerance
so we need to go back to the agenda now
which is item three
on the agenda which is to confirm the
minutes
of the joint meeting held on the 21st of
um
the 20th sorry of december 2021
jos stroke 21 stroke 24.
now are there any comments on the
accuracy of the minutes this is a baby
one or is it a paperwork no is that a
joint
well it's joint sorry yeah
any any points regarding the accuracy of
the minutes
have you got a comment
so i have two comments
thank you
i have two governments one is regarding
um point 15.8
[Applause]
um
[Music]
and and the fact that the the
information was to be made available to
full council i'm not aware that that
actually happened can you just identify
that for me again
bear with me a second
i'm not in i'm in the right same place
as you are
what's the you're talking about
oh sorry i'm i'm at the mid suffolk
overview which one are you at i'm
confused this is the this is the meeting
the joint meeting held on the 20th of
december 2021. so i apologize i don't
have a comment about wrong meeting yeah
councillor custer
yeah thank you proposal by councillor
casten seconded by councillor welland
thank you very much
so we then go on to
oh sorry
what
yeah
thank you each other but it's now in
progress
oh
council mclaren might thank you
please
that is seven votes four and two
abstentions that's correct
thank you
so we now go on to item four
which is bos stroke 21 stroke zero four
to confirm the baboon minutes of the
meeting held on the 17th of january this
item is for baby
members only
are there any points of accuracy and the
minutes that people want to raise
i'd like to propose that they are
approved
thank you council barrett seconded by
councillor osborne
thank you very much
and they will go to the electronic vote
thank you chair this spirit is now in
progress
councillor mclaren may take you verbally
please thank you that's three votes for
and one abstention that's correct so the
minutes of the meeting on the 17th of
january have been confirmed thank you
very much
item five
bos stroke 21 stroke zero five to
confirm the beyblade minutes of the
meeting held on the 21st of february
2022 this item is for baby members only
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
can i have a propose a please
counselor osborne
i'll have to there's only me left so i
will second that
as
councillor barrett was there in a
different capacity thank you
clear the votes now in progress
best
just finding the right button
it's your own personal choice a
counselor is not um prevented from
voting on minutes by virtue of not being
present at the meeting so even if you
were absent you can still vote it's just
your choice
abstentions
is that okay
there's no problem with that
right
so the minutes of the meeting on the
21st of february have been confirmed
so item six mos
stroke 21 stroke zero four to confirm
the mid-separate minutes of the meeting
held on the 13th of january 2022 this
item is for mid-suffolk members
only are there any
like cancer acting
[Music]
in the in the third line from the bottom
it's it i think a pound sign in front of
971 000 would make that more clear
and i and and in this next line down
where it says no raise i think that word
should be
rise um
and then
in 14.6 i think uh on the first line
which says countless cars
question the risk that a savings program
would
i think the word for should be deleted
and in in 14.7 i don't believe the
comment attributed to
council of whitehead in response
to my query is the answer to my query in
fact
at least i'm not entirely sure that it
is
what would you like there in its place
well i don't recall what councilman
white if that's what councillor
whitehead did really say then he didn't
answer my question
but that doesn't make it in an accurate
an inaccurate record is that
that was what was recorded
any more comments counselor scarf
yeah thank you page 27
14.12 which says councillor scarf
suggested that the overview and scrutiny
committee note the budget and asked the
cabinet to know comments that the
committee had made presented information
should be given ahead of the meeting
don't really give a true picture of that
i think it was the format of the
presentation to that meeting we we had a
powerpoint
imposed upon us
at no notice at all and that was really
what it was referring to the information
was useful but we were then
going to take a very long time looking
at the budget which we did do
and if that information had been
presented before
that would have been more useful so we
didn't have to go through it on the day
because i think it the impression was it
was
designed perhaps to limit questions from
members on the day
if that clarifies so i think
anything you would like to suggest as a
an alternative to that i think if we if
we say presented information should be
given ahead of the meeting uh and
councillor scarf quest questioned the
format the style of presentation at the
meeting perhaps that would cover it
that's all
have we got that person
oh you're doing it
okay
yes any more comments on the accuracy of
the minutes
can i have a proposal please
for
the midsuffoc officer will now conduct
the electronic vote
thank you to that place now in progress
that is four votes for in one abstention
that's carried
thank you so the minutes of the meeting
on the 13th of january 2022 for
mid-suffolk
overland scrutiny committee have been
confirmed
thank you can we proceed to item 11
which is the forthcoming decisions list
do members have any comments
no comments
counselor barrett
sorry are we are we on item 12
11
sorry where's that
so what is it
where is it then
okay thank you very much
so the next item is the work plans for
overview and scrutiny
and
um
does anybody have any comments about
you've received both work plans for baba
and mid suffolk
does anybody have any any comments
councillor hinton
okay thank you very much indeed just a
quick one on the
uh infrastructure delivery plan
um that is usually produced in about
september time so is this
to be looking at in july the one from
december
september
21 a lot because
these plans seem to come out
with all
with increasing frequency from the
planning and building and control
section
with great big differences between each
one
for instance multi-million pound
projects can disappear off one and
appear in another or not appear in one
and
disappear somewhere else so
it'd be nice to know which one are we
talking about here on the 18th of july
are we talking about the
2002
sorry 2022
joint delivery plan or the 2021 joint
delivery plan because infrastructure
plan because they they come out usually
in about september time
or they're dated september for coming
out in october november time right well
can councillor wallam and i have met so
councillor wallam is now going to give
you a report on where we are with the
idp thank you councillor
jer my understanding is we're not
looking at the detail we're looking at
the
strategic process
of coming up with the idp
who has an input into it
how it can be influenced and so on
not the items of infrastructure in the
list which
as councillor hinton says can change
from day to day
uh but it's to look at the strategy
behind it all particularly with
reference to the joint local plan
um part one or the first section of
which
the the the the bit refers to policies
rather than allocations we should have
some information on that by the time we
get to july
so that's that's the reason for it being
then is that we can look at it in the
context of
its production and
it the the way that it's aligned to the
the joint local plan
does that answer your question counselor
not really
chair because
the one thing that the infrastructure
delivery plan is supposed to do is to
supply the infrastructure to meet our
requirements which are largely dictated
by the local plan
uh and as the local plan is at the
moment up in the air because the
inspectors said that you've got to go
and strategically think about where
you're going to put these houses
etcetera then that is going to obviously
impact upon the
the needs of the infrastructure delivery
plan in terms of where
new roads go schools go medical profi
etc which are all these things that
suddenly appear and disappear off the
thing in the past well the houses are
being built
in in most places now
we should know exactly what
infrastructures needed to go with them
so it should be a much more detailed not
just the process
but
should have something in there because
we all know how long it takes for
anything to do with infrastructure to be
delivered
it's a bit like giving birth to a
half a dozen elephants all at once i
think sometimes well keith and i met
with tom barker and christine thurlow i
mean i personally
am wanting something even a bit more
basic than that i think many members do
not understand
the process of the infrastructure
delivery plan and what the
um
the sort of the route goes when when a
planning application has
been put into the planning department
and what happens after that
and so we're we're discussing that in
detail
but this meeting was has been delayed it
was supposed to be earlier on in the in
the work plan wasn't it
yeah chair if i if i may um i think what
counselor hinton wants to do is to
understand
how a particular development may affect
a particular piece of infrastructure and
vice versa
well that is a matter for each of the
two sovereign
councils to a to a larger degree it's
not that is not a matter for scrutiny
what is a matter for scrutiny is to make
sure the right things are being taken
into account
um
and and the right people are being
involved
and the the right decision making not
the not the not the specific decisions
but the
right way of going about the decision
making has been adopted
as you said chair a much more strategic
approach than the individual items of
infrastructure
that's all very well talking about
scrutiny but this document forms an
integral part of the
the lodge of documents that form the
local plan the joint local plan and it
does actually say delivery on there
so there should be some sort of
specifics as to where the houses are
being built and so forth
within that uh
discussion mechanism
that's probably not for this committee
uh you need to
no i understand that
okay
well can you
leave that with us and then it will come
up in the in the work plan
okay
uh chad uh just very briefly um on the
25th of april the work plan planning i
think is going to be a non-formal
workshop rather than part of the formal
meeting so in that regard i think it
needs to be
removed from the work plan but but not
removed from our work if you see what i
mean
a more appropriate one
not removed from our diaries yeah but
actually
we agreed that you agreed that before
the meeting with emily yeah
so that is it's a separate thing we have
to
review the draft empty homes policy and
that was the only place that that could
go but while you're here for the meeting
then that was we need to do some
training and empowering and
enabling committee members uh with
working on you know being on the
committee itself
have we got any more councillor barrett
sorry just can i just check with you
we've got draft empty homes policy is
that looking at a a specific development
of a policy to
to how we
how we uh reallocate homes it's not it's
not uh we we've often looked at voids
and the amount of time that voids have
taken to
to be um
turn around and uh re reallocated to
families so can i just clara
uh jerry this isn't to do with voids in
our own council homes it's more to do
with empty home empty homes which are
probably privately owned but have
remained empty for a while
and the process for encouraging the
owners to bring them back into use
it's related to an earlier paper that
came to us and it wasn't heard within
the work plan that's right isn't it
justin king wrote that
how's the scarf
well
it's in relation to the last point
actually because it it does reflect this
um on both our work plans we've got
improving access to the private rented
sector
um chairs to discuss the timing for
bringing this to the committee i mean
one of the ways of improving access to
the private renter sector is making sure
that empty homes are actually occupied
so i would like to see us
look at that
maybe that
actual particular date is too early to
look at a full report on that but um i
think it would be useful because the two
really are inextricably linked aren't
they
sorry just um on that
same point um will that include then
looking at the uh sort of the increase
that would be charged on an empty
property after 10 years of being empty
where it should go to 300
council
tax
can anybody answer an action
answer that question
counselor
don't i'm not i'm not sure that
but we need to bring that into our
policy but it is something to bear in
mind that's a that's a little bit like
the stick but we're looking more at the
carrot i think
on what
we as two
councils can do to encourage people to
bring
um unused
homes into use
i think kathy would like to have a word
about it i may have got that a little
bit wrong
and i guess at the meeting that might be
an element you would want to you'd want
to raise
any more comments on the work plan
can i just advise
we've we've had sort of
standard programmes over the history of
opium scrutiny and joint overview and
scrutiny i would welcome keith and i
would welcome
um
where members feel very strongly about a
certain service or
they feel
the need to scrutinize something we have
a broad remit
and i would welcome you know you to
recommend subjects to us wouldn't we
yeah absolutely chair and i think that
is
part of the
purpose or even the main purpose of the
work plan planning on the
uh
the non-formal part of the meeting that
we have on the 25th of april yes i think
we need to be a bit more
innovative in the subjects that we and
the things that we look at
so uh if you'd like to bear that in mind
well committee thank you very much for
your
patience this morning it's been a long
meeting
um
the
work plans are for note in bethany just
for the record
but i would like to conclude the meeting
the next joint overview and scrutiny
committee meeting will be on monday the
25th of april 2022 at 9 30 am thank you
very much
you